emily you've never sung the intro song
do you know it
i've never seen the show
is it
making your way through the world today
emily's uncle wrote winding roads what's
it called country roads and she thinks
she's lived like a
musical genius
the arrogance to sing whatever that was
it was the cheers theme song oh yeah
because we can afford that
[Laughter]
the great rob mcelhane is on the show
today
the great rob
mcelhenny
rob mcelhenny is here you just did how
is this possible
mac like big mac mcelhinney mcelhany
yeah mackel henny
rob mcelhenny
this is devastating because he's your
friend he's my best friend like i'm your
best friend he's we're best friends now
rob mcelhenny no
matter honey rob mcelhoney the fact that
the m and the c are so close to each
other it's confusing it is slightly
confusing
a lot of people struggle with this oh
why don't we i'm just gonna be still not
clear true friends can do this
so rob
mcelhenny and i
rob mcelhenny and i
have an understanding
which is that every now and then i'll
mispronounce his name
so that
he knows how good it sounds so yeah we
gotta keep him humble he's getting a
little too famous he's getting a little
too successful
his show came up
[Laughter]
it's going to be my last name one day so
i
he and caitlin are very in love which is
funny because i love her too so i know i
want them to be together but i want them
to be happy like it's going to be hard
for me when he falls in love with me and
she's hurt but i think she can i'll find
her yeah i don't think there's enough
tequila in the world but when i put out
something right i then second guess
myself i'm like i must be wrong about it
right right it's called self-esteem
folks anyway you know him from creating
uh and starring in it's always sunny in
philadelphia my second favorite show
after cheaters
he also created and stars in mythic
quest with some super brilliant people
uh i love this show so much i also love
that it's technically called mythic
quest ravens banquet and he goes out of
his way to name his show really long
names because he thinks it's funny which
is so brilliant
i have to say i am a true fan of rob's i
did not invite him on the podcast for
the longest time because i just didn't
want to
ruin
my fake relationship in my head with him
mm-hmm and i do think i bombed the
interview
i spent like a day
with ben bennett like console me i don't
i i think it's gonna be fine i just am
insecure about it because there's so
much i want to ask him and he's so
interesting and he's so smart and he's
so funny that i didn't
okay just let's just keep it
professional um and uh i also panicked
at the beginning of the interview and
you know that if i get a little what
does it call when you get something in
your
seed a worm a thought worm i thought
like you know when something worms what
it's called
a lug noodles noodles that's what they
say on mythequest let me noodle on it
yeah um but uh anyway so i i decided
okay rob's coming on the show he's
really tan right now because he's doing
playing the iron roll and myth the quest
who's really tan it's summer it's july
right right you know what right people
make fun of me and they say i look like
who's the goblin in lord of the rings
what is it the marilyn monroe voldemort
no no the one that's like with the ring
yeah
jeez
um read my comments wow i'm really
learning that you guys do not read the
youtube comments i read every single
youtube so then what are the insults
about me we blocked all of them oh
we blocked the word whitney
we blocked the word busted old not funny
crusty dusty musty
anything that is
so i was like you know what it was a
sunday rob was coming in i was you know
i'm gonna just throw it on a little self
tanner it's been a minute you know i
haven't put on self tanner in a minute
you can see the veins in my temples my
face is
translucent at this point and so i
didn't want to look like i had scurvy in
the interview compared to him i blonde
hair i already look like jaundice so i
took my little tickets to write it oh my
god you got it right i got myself uh
yeah to me all self tanners are the same
the sally han the one that's five
dollars and one's a hundred dollars like
whatever so i get it
you know you spray it on that doo-doo in
a bottle
and i put it on before i put my makeup
on because i was like okay it's just
gonna give me i just made a fake
timeline in my head of when it was gonna
hit right right oh god and i put it on
at like noon uh-huh and then i put my
makeup on and then he came in at two so
i was like i'm gonna just be like
sun-kissed sun-kissed yeah sun kiss
right right just half a basal cell right
i didn't want to look crazy right it
hadn't kicked in so i do have like a
bronze glow and then i put on my bronzer
oh god and then we're talking 10 minutes
into the interview i see the monitor and
i see that i full have a
skid mark i mean it's a skid mark on the
side of my face it looked like a bruise
for it it looked bet it looked like that
photo of lindsay lohan when she was egg
court and she had just a brown line on
the side of her face
so i caught a glimpse of myself and i
was in a panic and you know when you get
a pit in your stomach and it's like your
heart takes like a shit in your chest
and you're like of all the interviews
this is the one that i mean did he say
anything full rachel dolezal
no he didn't say anything but and of
course for me to be like i look tan like
what a shallow to even talk about myself
at all i was like so embarrassed but um
so i was distracted and a little bit
nervous and thrown and it's probably
something that nobody would notice but
me no i think other people i i know
i'm like this is probably just an
insecurity that only i have no no no
everybody noticed i think the naacp has
been ringing off we're gonna have to um
block out blackface from this i mean
i mean like it was like justin trudeau
level well it's just like a comical um
contour line but you can see that during
the interview when when i'm listening to
him i'm i'm my face is in my hands like
listening like the rodan thinker but i'm
really just trying to wipe makeup off my
face like i'm fully now why didn't you
just say i need a minute i have to go to
the bathroom
and stop
your chicken had explosive diarrhea if
you say i have to go to the bathroom no
not diarrhea just like hey we need to
stop down for a second tech problem he
doesn't have anything i can't come back
a different color
just saying that would be i come back
with a different face i blame pat for
this because he was in the room he has
never looked at me
pat is so nauseated
i would have said
pat's like this is the best you've ever
looked on the show like did you just get
back from sandro bay
this is the healthiest you've ever
looked
he's like you think this is bad
but during the entire interview my hand
is on the side of my face and i'm just
slowly trying to wipe it off as i'm
talking to him it it looks so i feel so
crazy in this interview he's of course
brilliant i look like i'm appropriating
a native american tribe he's talking
like about serious stuff super funny
stuff and i'm spending the entire time
trying to wipe my makeup off i look like
a remember
do you know i looked like an old copy
remember an old copy do you remember do
you know what that is
[Laughter]
it's such that's such a deep cut dude
should we get oh copy merch
i look like the lorax in this episode
but i and with the hair looking crazy
you guys are just letting me go on
camera looking like harley quinn's
grandma
i do feel like i look like javier bardem
and skyfall
and then i was looking up javier bardem
and skyfall and i realized i actually
look like all of javier bardem's
characters
mixed into one no country for old men
no look at my hair
look
so spot on
this is exact hairdo from no country for
all men
it's still not as bad as the globs when
i did uh when i did an episode where i
had globs of
blue on my head like i i was my hair was
growing out and i had just ordered this
new like
what is it silly putty it was a root
cover-up and i was just like putting it
in my house another time i was not here
while i was talking it was globs of blue
in my hair it looked like i
i
this is i was gonna say i look like i
blew a blue man and grace went you look
like you blew man group
i don't even get it but i cannot stop
laughing i look like i blew man group
anyway we need to pull it together with
the looks on the podcast i don't even
know if you guys watch it on youtube if
you listen to it if you're not watching
it you are missing a meltdown in real
time every time every time so we are
going to get to rob mcelhenny uh soon
couple announcements
next saturday august 7th i am going to
be performing stand-up comedy at the
mirage las vegas new material new me
undies let's do this and you know what
the cdc says what happens in vegas
gets treated with antibiotics in vegas
vegas show not just for vegas people
drive yeah come from l.a come from reno
come from wherever come from new york
come from
from just come i if you live in l.a this
is actually a great show to come to stop
at the madonna inn on the way one of my
favorite hotels on the planet i've never
been there really des moines iowa i'm
coming at you i'm going to be at the
hoyt sherman place it's not a palace
it's a place okay it's definitely a
place not somebody's
some of these venues are palaces some of
them are palatial palaces this is just a
place
to come see coffee
on october 15th
there's gonna be trouble in river city
and that is indeed a music man reference
because the most updated iowa reference
is in fact from the musical that
premiered in 1957. see you soon hawkeyes
there's someone um you know what someone
has a kid named hawkeye and i think
that's so cool
anaheim city national grove i'm going to
be at the city national grove october
22nd god i'm obsessed with these venue
names
i can't wait till there's like a
medicated goldmann arena
denver i will be at the paramount
theater october 23rd unfortunately i am
off the edibles at the moment so i guess
i'm just gonna have to go for a hike
or do crack
while i'm in town mile high city
milwaukee i'll be at the pabst theater
november 4th milwaukee overlooks the
menominee river which is shockingly not
the name of one of the tracks on john
mayer's latest album
shocking milwaukee is known as the cream
city well now that's on the john mayer
album why
no it made me cream city
when i heard this song why you now love
me yeah
i do think this is a good point
milwaukee is known as the cream city why
is no one talking about it i've never
heard that that's insane
why is there why is it not the only the
cream city why is that now why is that
not their slogan why
why is that on my slogan for the touch
me tour it is
we're gonna celebrate the bucks
championship win a couple months late
then i'm coming to orlando i'll be at
the hard rock live ooh from the cream
city to the harvard rock
november 13th there's something called
the fern forest nature center so if you
guys have any exotic animals you better
hide them you better hide them quick
because i'm going to come set them free
and you know this and i'll put you all
over instagram and i will i will smear
your business without the slightest bit
of research about whether you have
licenses or not
green bay i'm going to be at the meyer
theater on november 19th green bay
wisconsin i have never been to this
theater i'm very excited it's gonna be
very cold in green bay but you're all
used to that my nipples are not so i'm
gonna bring myself some
uh i'm gonna speak in the packers i'm
gonna be packing some aquaphor for my
nipples uh i also please tailgate to the
show bring your george foreman grill
crack a green 19
wear your finest cheese wedge hat from
lids
and let's do this
yes you can literally the shape of a
sheep i'm sure the wisconsin lids has a
cheese hat
or if it doesn't then i know what
business i'm opening when i get there
i'd like to eat it on the ground
shark tank
there's also a railroad museum
in green bay oh so i can remind myself
that although getting on a plane can
often suck it could be way worse
minneapolis i'm going to be at the
pantages theater on november 20th the
pantages i have arrived two shows at the
pantages theater what does pantages
stand for pantages means live forever
oh
come live forever at the pantages
theater with me even though i'll only be
there for an hour you can stay as long
as you want i won't be there forever but
if you are godspeed boise i'm going to
be at the egyptian theater december 3rd
and i'm not going to do the walk like an
egyptian thing i'm not going to put my
hands above my head and do that because
that is definitely cultural
appropriation are we still allowed to
call it the egyptian theater they have
to change that at some point
no because it's from egypt is it in the
shape of a pyramid
are there people out front like doing
this you just did it
that's if you're listening you're really
missing out on me getting cancelled did
you know that potato farmers in idaho
destroyed millions of potatoes last year
because there was a crop surplus you
know how many potatoes i've destroyed
backstage at improvs
it's very messed up has anyone ever seen
whitney eat a baked potato because she
hates it like a popsicle i eat it like
an apple
yeah
yeah no one takes down more spuds than
me
especially especially not in the chicken
in dream city
i would like someone to cream city on my
potato sour cream
i am very excited about that
columbus i'm coming to the joann
davidson theater you know what's so
funny about it's not real yes it's
called the joanne davidson theater which
i love because the first thing i thought
was like a woman could afford to sponsor
a theater like
who was her husband where did she get
this money who is joe and david davidson
does joey and davidson know that i'm
gonna be doing jokes about dick vanes in
her theater like i just pictured this
woman that spent money to have her name
on a theater cause she thought it was
gonna be like shakespeare
she thought it was gonna be the ballad
she thought it was gonna be all these
classy productions and i'm coming in hot
with cream city jokes
december the 9th i'll be there columbus
it was columbus right so real quick ohio
ohio state i want to talk to you because
i was on a morning show recently one of
your radio programs jimmy and the goat
or one of those
yeah like
bucky in the worm or whatever one of
these like
little morning shows and uh i said
something about ohio state and i was
like oh i love their red uniforms it
went dead silent they went hey hey hey
hey hey the uniforms are not red they're
scarlet
they were dead serious what did you do i
said that would have been no i was like
i just i'm this is the thing it's gonna
get me canceled do you hear me do you
have any idea
go google my roasts i've said so many
worse things than this anyway i'm sorry
for that i will make amends when i come
cleveland i'm gonna be at the agora
theater if you're agoraphobic i have bad
news
well you'll be inside to call the
theater the agora theater
joanne didn't name that one making fun
of agoraphobic people december 10th
congratulations though on the new
non-racist baseball team name yeah but
sorry you guys have to throw out all
those indian shirts i i mean i'm from dc
we have redskins no not anymore not
anymore but i'm just saying the amount
of redskins shirts and tank tops and
tube tops that i have that i've had to
throw away
um i mean just i just throw them in
there with all my all my harvey
weinstein hats
my bill cosby sweaters
not cosby sweaters like the ones he wore
on the show they're just sweaters
of just bill cosby's face god i got it
what are we gonna call it what did they
call it the cleveland you're calling in
the guardians the cleveland guardians
of the ball like what does that even
mean the guardians
i mean the cleveland guardians they're
out of names
the cleveland's better than the washing
the the washington football team i i had
a pitch for dan snyder about what
because the big thing is that that the
washington redskins he didn't want to
change the plane and the insignia so i
was like to reduce the amount of words
you have to change just call it the
washington foreskins
they did not
appreciate it that was it john move on
their part i concur
chicago i'm going to be at the vic
speaking of concurring
chicago the vic december 11th i'm doing
two shows nashville at the polk theater
january 28th you know i will be there i
will be everywhere except for kid rocks
bar
i love you guys the touch me tour
officially kicks off in points ponte
ponte vedra what's the point
this freaking name ponte vedra florida
september 10th two shows in one night
point measure someone sent me the
funniest dm they were like or it was a
comment and they were like hey we i used
to be really upset that you couldn't
pronounce miami oklahoma but i see that
you can't pronounce any cities in
america so i feel way less offended
there's only a few tickets left for the
seven pm show at the point vedra concert
hall it's in the hall it's not actually
the hallway actually it's actually just
in the hallway it's in the sky
it's the pawn veteran hallway
sebastian will be in the hall uh take an
adderall get it together get your
tickets second show is at 10 o'clock so
those tickets are available now the
following day on september 11th um
cancel your september 11th party and
come to my shows in clearwater florida
at the capitol theater there are almost
no tickets left for the 7 p.m show
because scientologists love me
we had a second show at 9 30 also
florida is like 20 miles wide so if
you're not if you're not
if i'm not going to be in your city in
particular drive up from tallahassee or
whatever kiss me whatever city named
after a native american tribe that hates
us um
but come peddle your wares come sell me
one of your airbrushed t-shirts i'll
sell you one of mine because we have
some coming you also have wares
um
uh you know that in florida they call it
they say they're some of the best
beaches in the world include clearwater
so we'll be going to those oh i didn't
know that yeah uh
when we're there they'll be the best
bitches in the world
so come on friends enemies long-lost
relatives you're all invited
and then i'm canceling the rest of these
shows because i i i can't even read
these announcements i don't know how i'm
going to do all these shows this is
insane enjoy rob mcelhaney don't ride
elephants
this this is gonna this is gonna be a
home run in our household it's so dumb i
just thought the puzzles could be cool
for the kids no i love it my we are
obsessed with animals certainly with
cats all of a sudden i didn't think i
was a cat person but i'm a cat person
and what about cats makes you a cat
person this one cat made me fall in love
that'll do it one cat we fostered i
think at this point six or seven cats
and they kind of came in we took great
care of them mostly my wife
and my kids and then we found homes for
them but this one cat i was like i i
think we should keep this what about it
he's just really um
snuggly and affectionate and he he's not
i mean i don't mind aloof like i can i i
can get on board with a cat wanting to
live his own life and just you know
whatever but i need a little bit of
something this cat is like a dog and so
far as um
i don't
even a dog our dogs and we have two dogs
who i love
there's a certain amount of neediness
that comes along with being a dog i
think and so their affection can
sometimes push into the neediness this
cat has wants affection wants love back
wants to wants to give affection wants
to give love and then everyone likes a
bad childhood yeah but no but then but
they can also be like fuck off like i
think this cat's secure whereas that's
why i love dogs so much because they're
just endlessly needing attention and
love and that's what i believe is a
healthy relationship sure well now we're
okay let's get into where one person
talks and the other is completely mute
and needs them to survive because you
know beth stern uh she fosters cats and
i remember one time i was um in new york
or something and i saw this family of
cats in new york like all eating on
something and i went over to try to say
hi to them they're obviously feral and
i'm talking and i'm like hey okay i just
found these cats with the dog you would
get them and i'm like what should i do
like do i try to trap them do i throw
you know blankets over them what am i do
i pick them up by their neck like what
do i do and she was like you leave them
alone i was like but they're they're
cats and
she was like well cats can live outside
and survive yeah and i was like then why
do we rescue them
which one is it
well i think what a lot i think in l.a
county what they do is they catch them
neuter them and then send them back out
because they can survive but they just
don't want them to propagate of course
of course of course and then i did
attempt to rescue a cat once i saw a cat
on the street in my old neighborhood and
it was walking around alone it was like
kind of you know and i brought him in my
house and spent a couple time days with
him give him food and sort of like
socializing him hanging out with him
taking pictures for social media to get
him a home
and then uh when i put on instagram my
neighbor uh came over and said did you
just try to
steal my dog give i was a cat give my
cat away that's amazing i was like i
didn't realize it was your cat it was
just out on the street yeah the cat's on
like he was like yeah she goes for a
walk every now and then yeah i was like
well okay
so i stole it yeah well
we're in the middle we're in the middle
of that negotiation right now because
our cat wants to go outside and
caitlin's like i'm afraid the coyotes
like i just don't want to get ripped
apart and i'm like well
i think cats are pretty resilient and
tough and he lived on the streets for a
long time but i do but will he come back
oh yeah
he loves me as much as i love him but
you have never tried to let the cat free
no no we've only had him for a month you
know what you can get there's um an item
called not today coyote
where
there's a ton of spikes on a vest
that you could get for your cat
it's it's like armor it's like it's like
it turns your animal into a porcupine
wait a second but hold on a second but
then you have to put that on every
single time he wants to go for a like go
outside and to me i'm trying to figure
out ways in which we have
less responsibility because right now
if you let him out you will have no
responsibility well i mean so far as
like leaving the door open like we leave
the door doors open for the dog so the
dogs can come in and out because they
can they're fine and then but now we
have to close the doors but then if the
dogs have to get out then they're
scratching at the window and then we
have to go so i'm trying to figure out
ways
yeah i know that animal whack-a-mole
thing yeah but if you have a yard can't
the cat just go in the yard well yes
but then i mean the cat could
but we've had coyotes in the in the
backyard before yeah yes yeah fuck
around no they don't no they a friend of
mine
uh that you probably know came home to
her chihuahua
it was not only dead but the head was on
one side of the yard and the body was on
the other side of the yard i mean they
decapitate the animal yeah it's not just
i'm gonna kill your animal and fuck up
your day it's like i'm gonna make you
look at the inside of the thing you love
i've got a couple friends who have
similar stories and my we have a bigger
dog and a small dog a french bulldog and
he i'm a little bit nervous about it you
should be and the cat i'm actually less
nervous about because the cat can defend
or jump or yeah yeah but those frenchies
are
well i mean they can hardly breathe much
less yes that doesn't want to fight yeah
they are genetic mutants okay i love you
i'm nervous about being on your podcast
why
because i'm always nervous about um
doing podcasts that are that are so uh
first of all hosted by comedians but
then also have so many comedians on
because i'm i'm concerned that i can't
be that it's just not going to be funny
you oh don't you worry so this is on the
other side of my yard at all times those
coyotes
they come out every day at five
a huge pack and they look healthy they
do not look skinny they're fine and then
every
couple weeks i see a sign in my
neighborhood lost cat
like bitch if you want me to find your
cat i'm gonna need to cut a coyote open
yes yeah you gotta be you gotta be
careful i'm nervous about this too
because i
am
like a real fan of yours uh personally
professionally do you remember the night
i ambushed you and your wife at a party
yes and embarrassed myself deeply
i i wouldn't consider that well i can't
speak to how you felt but i was uh very
excited by it uh i know exactly when it
was and where it was and what and what
the party was and all that was in
beverly hills was in a restaurant caa
party yes and it was around the emmys
and
um
not that either of us were nominated for
empty no no no no no no but we were
going to the various parties and but i
but i had met you years prior yes and i
don't know if you remember that because
i told that story to you
and i think that i had disassociated
that whole moment yeah yeah i was i saw
exactly
i saw you uh
perform stand up i think this would have
been season one of sunny i did know this
yeah i think
it made me want to quit yeah it was in
season one of sunny and we were looking
for writers
and you and you were um and i saw you
perform i don't even go out and see that
much stand up but for whatever reason we
were there and i think i actually think
rogan
was there too i bet improv this one
yeah yeah and this would have been 2 000
2005. wow i just could not have been
that good by that time you were so funny
so then i got your information i don't
remember how i got your information but
then i was like begging you to come
write for sonny for whatever reason it
didn't work out
i remember very specifically and tell me
if this was just something that you
transitioned when you transitioned out
of this because i find it fascinating
you you held the microphone in a very
specific way
i'm gonna do it with this mic it might
mess it up a little bit but you held it
like this it's also how i hold a dick oh
yeah yeah so i just depending on hold of
the weight all today sure well this is
clearly the girth of a penis
so uh yeah you held it you held it like
on your fingertips like this
was that
it was very specific and i was like that
is a
that's either like a weird choice that's
so funny or she's doing that
unconsciously and that's funny too it is
a weird choice that i used to make
because at the time i started doing
stand which was which was them and then
we will not talk about me anymore okay
um uh
i i everyone told me you're so strong
you're so raunchy like you're so
powerful like you need to sort of make
yourself more feminine and i just i
wasn't willing to change my clothes i
wasn't willing to not do the jokes i
wanted to do and talk about the things i
wanted to talk about or be aggressive
and take up space but i did think it
would be funny to be like like a dainty
little girl yes like here's my this is
my concession so anyway like i would
just do it like that okay yeah i tried
i've never heard i've never seen anybody
hold a microphone like that before
or since when did you transition out of
that well it was once i started becoming
a very physical comedian there was no
way because now it's kind of more like a
sport to me like it's very physical i
can't wear my hair certain ways because
i'm flipping over and i'm back and it's
in my mouth like there's just i'm it's
almost like you're going to work out and
i could only use one hand and then also
when i started to get more confident
with ticks with dicks uh i'm still not
confident with dicks okay um but uh and
how are we holding those at this point
we don't touch them okay that's good no
no no no we don't hold it okay i have a
house i don't have to do that yeah okay
and then no i think once i i started
getting confident and realizing you know
because there's silverman i mean the
people that came before me
that i looked up to i think all had a
very sort of like and it was also cool
at the time there was a big alt scene
that was like you just you don't touch
the microphone you sit there you tell
your jokes you don't exert a lot of
energy because you're too cool for
school and your your jokes are on a
notebook and you just go
so what else is happening
and then you tell like a labyrinth joke
and so um i actually think that was a
part of i i i think you would say like
so what else
well that means i was yeah but it was
fucking scared i was probably scared
yeah but it was working or i was um
that was a way to have power because it
was i realized very quickly the faster
you go the more you need their approval
the more they will not respect you and
will start to check out
and so i think for me the what else is
happening was like i'm taking my space
here and i'm not afraid of silence
i think it was kind of that well it
worked or i was just completely i i
begged you to to write for sonny and
um
i don't think you turned me down i think
it was just like oh well let's keep
talking and then it was a scheduling
thing and then we connected again
because you were going to have super
fans come in
to the writer's room yes that was after
the party that was way low oh that was
like eight years later we wanted to do
something for like what we thought was
going to be the final season was have a
couple of like
like killers come in that we knew who
were like fans over the years and coming
in i remember you called me and i pulled
over to the side of the road yeah and
like sat there and i was like it was
like so surreal yeah and then that
didn't work out for some reason and then
so i've tried you know what i'm trying
then there was another thing that i
asked you about and then but you were
running roseanne or something like that
at the time yeah that went great yeah
obviously i made the better choice
it did go great i mean i don't know what
it was like emotionally um
physically or how how it affected your
your mental health however the show was
great thank you yeah thank you and i
want to talk about this because i think
so i always try to not ask the questions
everybody else asks i see you was
looking at all your interviews every
question was like the same thing and
it's just we're not going to talk about
your body if someone wants to hear about
his body he's talked about it on every
other podcast it only in hollywood like
if i i couldn't go on a show and
somebody like so your body like you lost
all this weight you gained all this
weight so it's kind of interesting to
now
see men sexually harassing other men and
objectifying them it's kind of like
progress in a way
yeah and i don't and i think i think
just because of the historical power
dynamic like i don't feel objectified in
fact it's i ca i don't mind talking
about it just because i do find it
fascinating
and dax and i are constantly discussing
it and so men being insecure about their
bodies is a win for me i'm into it it's
a win for all of us yeah i think what
you'll find is that the vast majority of
men are insanely insecure about their
bodies they just can't talk about or
don't want to talk about it because
by far i would say 99.9 of the people
who are interested in
in my um whether i gained a bunch of
weight or lost a bunch of weight and
want to talk about it it's all dudes yes
all these women could give two flying
foxes i know and it's also yeah they're
like that's just our life all the time
yeah like i had to do this crazy regimen
why did you do this i'm like yeah that's
just life has been life for us since we
were teenagers but it's also kind of
interesting to me that if a man you know
puts on a bunch of weight and loses much
weight like they can like win oscars and
stuff and like if a woman puts on weight
she just gets fired
i want to point out i didn't win any
oscars or emmys because can i i'm sorry
can i say this i don't give a shit
anymore they're all bought and they're
all rigged like what are we doing it's
just like who's gonna put a bunch of
money into you know
those yeah i mean put it in i'd rather
put it in the show i don't yeah i don't
i don't really know how it all how it
all works i will say that um
you know you were just nominated for
like 20 emmys
no that's the other show on apple yeah
on mq yeah we're talking about this
yeah no no the
ted lasso was nominated for well we got
nominated for a box you did you got a
bunch yeah that's cool come on but the
other show's been going on for so long i
know and it's good well here's the dude
that show i didn't want to talk too much
about it because i know benton's going
to talk about it when he comes i just my
experience with sunny is so
hilarious to me the the show is already
i mean it might be my favorite show i
feel weird i would only i'd usually say
that if you weren't around uh the
comeback is maybe my favorite show and
then like that i've watched every
episode but then when i was dating in my
20s and early 30s it's every guy i've
ever dated's favorite joe i think it's
every guy's favorite show and it's like
they're they think it's like their
little secret and so when they want to
get serious they're like i want to show
you my favorite show like i'm going to
show you and i'm like oh yeah i've seen
that and i have to kind of pretend i
haven't seen it and i would say why do
you have to do that because you don't
want to take the win out of there they
have this thing they want to show me you
know and they have this like thing they
think they're teaching me something and
they can't really teach me anything else
you have to navigate the male ego yes
it's like when they want to like explain
hockey to me or something i have to be
like oh my god that's ice like that was
water once oh my god like i have to kind
of just let them have one sure and uh
i would say three out of five the their
favorite episode is green man and really
yeah
that's surprising to you yeah i'm always
surprised at what seems to connect with
the that fan with the fan base which has
now is now grown because our our
demographic has always remained
staunchly men and women
and and like i think season seven or
season eight was when we transitioned to
where more it was it skewed more female
which is odd and it's it's continued on
that trend well because caitlyn is
saying legend sure and she's not she's
not like oh he's talking about boys and
makeup and this she you know like women
were sick of just these every character
uh female character in every show just
being like
the housewife or the insecure one or the
one that like wants the guy to call her
back and the one who's like a stalker
and he's like can we just drive by my ex
boyfriend's house like who are these
people yeah well yeah i don't know at
some point they they it it just sort of
sort of shifted but it's always remained
staunchly 18
people 18 to 34. but the show's been on
for
it's 15 seasons but 17 years so that
means it's been like a generation of
people that have kind of aged in and
then aged out i'm starting to think that
maybe the reason the guys that i've
dated that's your favorite episode is
because they all secretly want to be
actors once something works you got to
beat it into the ground so you keep
bringing back
why do we do that that's the thing is
like people go like like oh we already
did that let's do it again in a weirder
way because characters are going to be
different two years later like let's
revisit that yeah and when you're doing
something for 15 seasons you have to try
to find ways to both
like the the trick i think of of sunny
and why it's continued uh to be
successful for as long as it has is
because we care about it we still want
it to be good and also because we
recognize that
uh that we want to deliver to the
audience the same show in a different
way every week so that they don't and i
think part of the charm of the show is
that you never know what the fuck you're
going to get
but that and sometimes that upsets
people so we'll do a weird ass episode
and then the fan base like hates it but
i think that even subconsciously there's
something that they enjoy about it
because they're like i'm not gonna get
the same joke that's right every single
time that's right and that's the i think
that's the way that we approach the show
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with approaching it a different way like
one of my my favorite shows of all time
uh is golden girls probably like top
three of my favorite shows
and you could take it still holds up and
you can i watch them with my kids now on
on lifetime that's
yeah and and and
we watch them and i'm realizing like oh
yeah you could take out every almost
every single script of golden girls and
just and just as a template and then
just erase the the
specific of the joke but take the but
take the intention of the joke blanche
says something sexy sophia's the wild
card rose says something dumb and every
episode is essentially the same
but
for whatever reason the genius of the
writing the genius of those actors they
made it feel both comfortable and
surprising week to week
i don't know if this is going to get me
in trouble
but i almost uh split with someone
buying the golden girl's house
it was for sale
what why i
i know where that is because i walk by
it quite often really because remember
it was for sale yes and they're doing um
lando entertainment they do that they
did the brady bunch house thing they're
gonna restore basically the golden
girl's house exactly what the set was
and i almost did it and then i was just
like
i too almost did it my i i i talked
about it with caitlin quite a bit and
then we were trying to think like
how can we justify this but if we can go
in with somebody and then they're gonna
restore in the tv show so let me i'm
going to ask them yeah you can just you
should just shoot a couple study
episodes in there like not at all
acknowledging
like that's just someone's house well
but like that's kind of the beauty of i
don't know when i was a kid and i would
watch that show i would watch that with
my with my mom who i i would see every
other weekend so we would go there and
like saturday nights were like that was
the best because we watched the golden
girls and then and then like growing up
um like california los angeles it was
just a completely like those women
actually existed somewhere in florida
yeah the idea that
there were people making a television
show is like surreal to me then you come
out here and you start seeing
like that that even just the exterior of
that house is not in florida why
wouldn't they even have shot that in
florida what the fuck it's just because
it's two humans it's too human so they
just went to that neighborhood and they
then they shot that and then
they and then the fact that they built
the set on this stage here
and now i live my betty white is my
neighbor
my neighbor insane it's crazy it's crazy
and
we have like she's so sweet and we leave
things for her and she calls we have
conversations on the phone and like over
covid um i would love to see her ring
camera footage of people that just drop
things
yeah because she loves animals more than
people and so what we do is we
we
we send photos of the animals like we
send photos of the kids but we cut the
kids off and it's just the animals so
like and then what kid looked the most
like what animal which one kind of like
was like hmm not too far off um my
oldest son axel looks kind of like the
cat
i would say if they had to yeah but what
we do is like we'll put them in like a
group and then those are the pictures
we'll send to like our parents and then
when we send them to betty we just like
cropped the kid out and i think she
appreciates like not having to see the
person because i don't know because
she'd much rather see the animal because
now that you're here i want to
talk to you about this because part of
the reason i love your work so much i
always felt like i had to choose you
know i always loved watching roseanne
growing up because it was super super
funny hardcore
jokes jokes things that were inherently
funny
pathos at the end and you it was
everything it was everything you would
laugh you would cry they did the episode
where dj wouldn't kiss the black girl to
school play like they did all these the
um
uh the lesbian kiss um it's not sandra
bullock it's
uh sandra bernard bernard and um and so
all these things it was like i was
learning i was laughing i was crying
that when jackie came in and her
boyfriend beat the shit out of her like
that
you know but i also just love straight
up dumb shit sometimes like i want to be
the most clever at everything but
sometimes i just love dumb shit and i i
love watching your shows and just
recently mythicquest because there are a
couple things that are just like like
silly physical comedy that i miss so
much like um three's company was my uh
sort of that was my shit i'm curious is
there anything that's like your
indulgence that's like like i love a you
know there's um
uh him trying to get into a hammock is
the funniest thing ever john ritter
there's a five minute video of him on
the internet of him just trying to get
into a hammock and he and it's so
brilliant when people fall i think it's
funny i have such a juvenile side to me
yeah you know is there anything that
you're like
yeah well i mean to me one of the
top five best moments of sunny um is
just straight up slapstick humor where
my wife
is in a shoe store and she comes
stumbling out of a shoe store and
fucking slams her head into the side of
a car and dents the shit out of it and
if you track it and you notice like we
were not a big production at that point
there's no visual effects there that's
her doing it and there was a stunt woman
on on set with us and she did one too
but kaitlyn's like no i'm doing it i'm
doing it i'm doing it and we were like
uh oh okay so i want to die i want to
get off the show so she's the guy in
address she did it and fucking and
nailed it and if you go back and watch
that episode there's no trickery like
she actually does stumbles falls down
and cracks and dents that car that is so
it's wild it's wild and so
that that kind of humor to me
just still like totally works and so we
do that in mythic quest as well every
once in a while we'll just do something
that's just so silly and stupid and even
though
sunny tonally uh it sort of lines up
more with sunny tonally mythicquest a
different kind of show every once in a
while i just we just can't help
ourselves i just i love that shit
there's a nice like respite for like
juvenile comedy it's just and sometimes
it doesn't make any sense so like
we have we have something happened in
the second season where and just one of
the writers pitched it and we were like
yeah like it's a it's definitely a bit
it's a gag it has nothing to do with the
rest of the scene that doesn't tie in
thematically it's literally just a
comedy bit and it's um charlotte
charlotte's character poppy has been
sitting cross-legged on oh i laughed out
loud yeah but then she was such a genius
i'm so curious how many takes uh she did
also just the um when she has to sit in
the beanbag chair to talk to that
like dumb shit that's just like
humiliating and so human and um when she
fell she was like screaming like it
still hurt like it just went on
uh
in real time and you're yeah i remember
and we don't get a lot a ton of notes
because actually the studio is like
really in support of the show but i
remember getting a few like hey can you
just shorten that and i was like nope
nope that's the thing no no we're not
going to shorten that the longer it goes
on the better if in fact if we shorten
it then it's just not going to be funny
there was a comedian named josh fadam in
la and he was really physical comedian
he was just like always be out of breath
like running on stage like he would just
do weird experimental shit and one time
he did this bit where he was like
started running and for the first minute
it was pretty funny and then the second
minute it was like okay buddy like
whatever like okay what are we doing
like all comedy's a nightmare like maybe
cut the adderall what's up
third minute people are leaving they're
getting up and leaving yeah
yeah
minute four
we are laughing so hard i don't even
know the biological basis for laughing
at something like that crying ball and
crying like how did he know
how did he get through that minute and
then that third minute and know that the
fourth was going to be
that magical and then knowing when and i
don't know
what happened there but like knowing
when when it's over how do you know what
it's it's so fast it's a gut i mean it's
an incident yes you have to know but i
love that and she just like fell
straight forward it was it was very um
john cleese or something it was like
instead of because a lot of people would
be inclined to maybe like catch
themselves she just knew it did go board
straight and just fall she kind of looks
like a muppet like the way she doesn't
look like him but she acts like a muppet
yeah
yeah and so we write to that well we
realized that season one and so we
started right into that season two so
i'm obsessed with uh mythicquest we will
keep talking about sunny in and out but
i want to ask you some questions
because did you see the video i sent you
where my boyfriend and i yeah it was one
it was wonderful i i caitlyn and i
watched it twice and i was like i don't
even know what she's talking about i
have theories isn't it so weird when
someone comes up to you and has a huge
theory about something you made but they
think they're right about it yeah but
the thing is you are right about it
that's what i love like i i truly mean
that like just because i put it out
doesn't mean that i'm
right like we have an intention of what
you put out but then however someone is
receiving it is up is up to them it's no
longer my business it's become like a
rorschach test yes so if you say if you
ask me uh is is that what it is i'm
gonna say is that is that what you want
it to be because that's what then what
it is for you if you ask me if that's
what i was intending i'll give you the
honest answer okay okay so
the episode after the episode where cw
and rachel are talking about how to slow
down to have story slow down and wait
and watch the story when the horse is
dying i'm not doing the spoiler alert
thing i do spoilers uh i do not believe
that you don't
i do at a certain point like you're
either gonna like watch it or don't if
you believe the entire world should not
talk about a show because you haven't
seen it yet you're fucking spoiled so
i'm going to talk about it um i guess
this whole thing was like stop stop i'm
like no you we got rid of that in the
writers room where i think we had a
i think it was a show that had been on
for like eight months or so you know up
on netflix and we were just like fuck
you guys like
leave the room we're talking about it
like when star wars came out it was like
so han solo he dies at the end
everyone's come on man it's been two
years yeah this is on younow um
so
when uh because i also am fascinated by
that show because i guess this is what
i'm putting on to it
so much of it feels like being in a
writer's room so much of it is i feel
like a metaphor uh at least for me and
uh so when cw said don't fast forward
through the story you gotta stay for the
story even though action might stop uh
and then the horse is dying and it's
emotional rachel starts crying and she's
moved and whatever then the next episode
you did was a standalone episode with
kristen and jake
and as soon as i realized i wasn't going
to see iron or poppy i got a little bit
of an itch and i was like okay let me
just i went you know i watched this one
later cause it's a standalone i can
watch it anytime so let me just finish
all the ace stories for this and then
i'll go back and watch this later like a
little mini movie
and i was like oh my god that was the
theme of the last episode don't fast
forward to the story
and then
alex came down my lover my handmaid
and he was like no that's not it at all
it's a metaphor for the entire show and
i was like no this show's a matter
that's not a thing i was like you're a
doctor you stay out of this i'm a writer
i know how this works you don't write a
metaphor for sure you write the show and
the show has themes and could have
metaphors but it's so obvious because
the episode before this was about this
anything i want to see it the way you i
want to receive it the way you intended
yeah so
we approach mythicquest in a completely
different way than we approach sunny
which is that with sunny we have sort of
like a macro understanding of what the
show is that developed over time and
then we just write
what we think is the funniest episode
based on
putting the whatever it happens to be
popular in western culture through this
like very bizarre prism and like meat
grinder of the point of view of the show
and then we just put that out uh and
with mythiques is completely different
we approached that show um
as uh
almost like thematically first where we
say like what are the interests what are
the things that are interesting to us
um what are things we want to talk about
every day in the writer's room yeah and
not necessarily always laugh which is
with sunny we have really in-depth
conversations um
because we can't fuck that show up we we
walk such a razor thin line
that we got to make sure that your your
fans own you yeah
and also it is a religion and also
people who aren't fans uh we can
recognize look you're never gonna change
somebody's mind but we have to make sure
that we're being respectful of whatever
the subject is that we're satirizing
right so that's a really that's a really
role in satire is making sure that
you're that you're being respectful of
all sides that you're never punching
down that you're that you're trying to
say something that um
that that
at least um whether it should or
shouldn't be said uh that at least
should be part of the conversation right
because it's a part of the cultural
zeitgeist i was trying to look up how
many hours of uh it's always sunny have
been made
i can tell you how many have been
watched because they we got that stat
last
i was just like if someone to start
watching it now how many hours would it
take to watch the whole thing because
these are people that have given you
hundreds of hours of their lives i mean
it's like it's so wild to think about
um we last year they told us that two
billion hours of sunny had been watched
which is crazy what happens when you
hear that
i wonder
i yeah i don't know i it's a it's a it's
such a staggering number but do you kind
of just go push it down push it down
can't process like i'm just gonna keep
going i don't want that to fuck with my
head it doesn't fuck with my head okay
because the show doesn't feel like um to
me it's never felt like a big hit
because it isn't a big hit it's it's
become a hit in the aggregate but it's
there was never a moment where we were
like uh a talked about show
ever and i mean the comedy community i
guess we talk about it so much i mean to
the point to where it's like you have a
bit you want to do and like fuck they
kind of did that on sunny damn it like
it's talked about a lot that's cool to
hear and i love hearing i mean we don't
like we're mad at you yeah yeah it's not
we don't like you
but i love hearing that when people are
like oh in our writer's room you know we
even on dramas and things like that we
talk about sunny
for the first 15 20 minutes and then we
and then and then we'll continue on with
whatever the story is and that obviously
feels really good but i'm not in those
rooms i can't feel that or hear that
yeah and then when we premiered the show
it was like a good five or six years
before
uh before social media so there was no
way to tell whether or not people were
watching it or caring or anything so i
had no feedback what whatsoever and
until we started doing the live show yes
which is also a good thing i'm not
complaining about it because in some
ways we were just working in a vacuum
and then that created what our um what
our process became and then continues to
be to this day which is if it makes us
laugh that's the only thing we care
about yep yep that's it and do you have
any like dumb writer's room jokes like
just dumb ones that no one would know
that like a like a like a inside joke
that's been going on this whole time you
know like like the dumb ones you know a
lot of writer's rooms do as you know and
it's regarding re you know uh and it'll
be a is that a semicolon what's the
thing that's two dots on top of each
other and then um
rey mark right raymark and then and then
people go like ah he's not available
like just stupid it's so dumb but we say
it to make fun of the people that would
say that and you know or like the who
jackie in the roseanne home you know
that's a big one any time it was jackie
so are there any that just like for
sunny dorks
um i can tell you that um for years and
years and years um one of the things
that we would say is
there's already laughing already
laughing there's already laughing
there's an episode that we want to do
like you know you come in the first
the first day and you're like okay i
want to do an episode about this what
about this what about that what about
this and then i don't know starting
season like
sit five maybe
we were like i was like i want to do an
episode that takes place entirely in a
water park like just just a water park
and then
we'd break the rest of the season and
then we'd be like the final episode uh
the water park thing's not really
working and then the next year we'd be
like okay we won't do this episode this
episode
i want to do that water park
and then
and then i think it was finally season
you might be able to look it up 12 or
something where
i was like okay and then of course we
have to do the water park and then and
then for whatever reason maybe because
we ran out of other ideas we were like
fuck it and we just put it up there and
we decided that we were gonna break the
story and it became like one of the
favorite one of the best episodes of
sunny we ever did
and for 10 years it was always just
sitting up on the whiteboard should we
do it in your water park episode like
always yeah it was always like
oh yeah all right rob let's do the
fucking
and by the way the story that we broke
is insane but it it seemed to work
because i was thinking about mythicquest
i do in the next season believe they
should have to be in charge of building
the amusement park version of
mythicquest
that's a good pitch i know that's a
really good picture yeah i also think
what about the uh there's gonna have to
be episodes of when they want to make
the movie version and then real actors
come in audition like real as them ryan
reynolds comes in and auditions for the
mastermind for that role yeah yeah with
the role of iron yeah yeah exactly who
would who would audition for the role of
i and that
ryan couldn't pull it off i think your
friend no he's not strong enough can i
tell you my little ryan reynolds story
sure i've never i've i've sort of seen
him around well first of all he was
married to atlantis more said at some
point so he's always cool with me
but
when i was in college in philadelphia i
worked for the u-pen television station
it's a big the nielsen ratings were
through the roof and i for some reason
they were like hey ryan reynolds he's
the star of this movie called um
lampoon's college whatever he's been van
wilder van wilder shit uh and he's on a
show called two guys and a girl in a
pizza place
and we need you to interview him
the fact whoever his publicist was the
fact that they allowed this to happen
i hope they have been fired and are
making see the crossover though van
wilder was about a year college time
yeah
i went into his hotel room at the four
seasons
in philadelphia already there was
someone there or whatever um no by the
way not
you and ryan the two people i've never
felt any weirdness with ever it was he
were the only two people probably wow
probably wow maybe like vern troyer
you know i mean i mean there's a couple
people that i haven't had a ton of
chemistry with but but you don't at
least there was no like you don't give
off the creep vibe there was no like was
this weird it was just like we're here
to work hi nice to meet you like it was
like you could shake my hand there's
women we just know and it's it's really
hard to explain also and it makes us
seem crazy it's like the the long hug
you know we can tell you exactly how
long was too long
and it's we talk about this all the time
this is the exact kind of thing we put
into mythicquest yeah because it's so
fascinating to us and to my partner meg
very specifically because these like
because workplace dynamics is
thematically interwoven with
i mean look i don't want to tell you
you're wrong
but you're wrong
no i i couldn't even follow what you
were talking about it would have been
better if that was the intention do you
want the video that you sent me which
you should put up into the show i sent
this video to you yeah and this was
right as i was binging your show
yeah my lover my ignorant young lover
so you're telling me you have to see it
that after an episode where the big
lesson is don't skip through the
emotional story parts
the next episode
is an emotional story part
similar
to the horse dying but you don't think
that is why they put
the episode
there
no
no water to that theory it's not there's
no water it's that you're missing the
point
how you're not wrong you're just
partially right
how do you know what's your
version that it's a metaphor for the
whole series
yeah
okay everything's a metaphor for
everything
but don't you think they put this
episode after the episode where the
whole lesson was don't miss the power of
story the power of story and then i
found with the next episode i didn't see
iron i didn't see all my friends for 30
minutes and learn about a new story but
how do they know i'm binging it
everyone binges everything
okay
it came out in 2012 i thought i made
generalizations uh but okay it came out
in 2020 everyone been doing everything
also even if you don't binge it you're
still going to appreciate
you don't think it's a coincidence that
there was an episode where the beast i
told you to shut the fuck up and donate
fast forward for 30 minutes yes i don't
think it's coincidence and then i saw
two brilliant actors that i love but it
was like oh this is like a standalone
episode and ayan's not in it and i want
to see the rings on all of his fingers
and i want to see what happened yes um
with poppy and the string dana because
she just got a promotion keep wanting
and then they went to someone else and i
was like oh i gotta get back and i
started fast forwarding and i was like
oh my god this is just what the guy told
me not to do 30 minutes of what could
happen over five or ten seasons
it's the whole point this is your show's
gonna break us up so thanks
also what are your credentials as a
writer i'm gonna tell you this the vet
is nailing it
no yeah this makes me think i can never
enjoy shows as a comedy writer it's like
he gets to do it i'm so jealous of the
people that don't make comedy they get
to watch it and just enjoy it i can't
believe it
i have never spilled a glass of goddamn
water in my life especially
i'm so
uh
glad that happened when dr david
sinclair was on the show i spilled an
entire coffee
uh on myself i am so sorry i shouldn't
have why are you sorry i should have
given you a difference by the way this
is because i should have made it a baby
bottle with a nipple this is something
we talk about on the in the myth request
writer's room quite a bit too
uh again workplace dynamics i just
spilled hands we have sweatpants i
spilled a bottle of water on your table
and on myself and on your chair and you
apologize because you're a big like hulk
now and you can't control you're just
like a big and now you're apologetic now
you're complimenting me
you're a big creatined up fucking id for
me okay sorry i'll get us back on the
rails um so that your producer doesn't
shoot you um
that you're the vet is correct
that you're you're partially right in so
far as the whole show is
is is woven together based on very
specific thematics right however the
specificity of what you're talking about
is unintentional
but that doesn't mean
that it didn't um that it wasn't
effective for you because it's still
saying the same things that we're trying
to say so it's genius and then also
accidentally genius on top of that yeah
obnoxious stuff it happens all the time
where you're like oh i wasn't intending
for this to be the case but they think
that i was and so therefore
the less i say about it the better or it
was like some subconscious thing that
you just no but again why did you put
that episode there
because because maybe again maybe it was
subconscious like you said because we're
these are the kinds of stories that
we're trying to tell even just the idea
that um because i've heard that we do a
bunch of those kinds of episodes where
we
tell the story in a different way and
people will call them like oh those are
departure episodes or those are
standalone episodes and they're not
it's just a different
way of telling the same story all the
themes yeah and then it all comes back
uh together at the end of that
particular season season one where the
same where the two uh characters in the
episode are going through the same
struggles as the two
uh main characters i am and poppy and so
uh the fact that we're navigating all of
that through
a series of episodes is not is yes it's
intentional but then sometimes the
specifics are unintentional but still
work fascinating and then i know um i
don't know where obviously the show is
going i mean my pitches will obviously
um uh be in season three but um
i i really did appreciate the first
episode of season two
we'll see if this what this means but i
appreciated the complete lack of sexual
chemistry between ayan and poppy in the
first season yeah because every network
would go they got a date they got a date
they got a date like scully and mulder
it's gotta be that and it was just like
so refreshing to go no men and women can
kind of just work together and not fall
in love
yeah
that's what we're dealing with yeah were
you just like was there any pressure on
you like at any time to sort of cheat or
be sloppy about well what if they
flirted or what if that you know no
never felt that way no because um
because
um
first of all
i mean i have this relationship with my
partner megan gans and so i love her
she's the best and so um we work very
closely together we have a very
like incredibly intimate relationship
and so i think what what winds up
happening or has historically happened
happened is that people start to
conflate
uh and i don't want to say just male
female i mean people of whatever sex is
attracted to the sex that they happen to
be working with and then they conflate
those intimacy those intimate moments
with romantic moments that's right so we
certainly the two of us have developed
uh a love for each other it's like the
idea you pitch the same joke at the same
time you know you're like in the banana
falls
yes you you were right here this whole
time yes it's like no you just
you're right it's funny but yeah we can
we what we recognize is like oh that
makes us great
partners and i and we love each other
and we we can be intimate with each
other but that doesn't have to then
take another step people are like oh
well then the next step would be this
and i was like well
i mean truly i don't know why that's the
next step why does there have to be
you've worked with a billion women and
never yeah exactly i've worked with a
billion men and we haven't we've and we
haven't had sex yeah like we've shared
and we've shared all those same levels
of intimacy and love whether men want to
talk about that shit or not yeah that is
what happens and then and then it
doesn't extend into the realm of sexual
so why would that be the case with well
with a person who i was sexually
attracted to uh every time right you can
separate those two things so
um and and and it's not even like a like
something that we're consciously doing
it's just something that we can i don't
know i'm so curious if that that is
something that we inherited from movies
because that was sort of the plot of so
many movies for so long right and then i
wonder if it's like nature and nurture
if that's something that's just human
nature that we kind of you know our
brains start to have the oxytocin and
norepinephrine if we're like we just had
the same joke that was so cool obviously
if it was a girl we'd be like high five
is there something of like you should
procreate with that person because that
person gets you and can raise your child
there's also something yeah that's just
like a biological imperative right so we
i will say that that for as many
accolades as we get for like creating uh
or at least demonstrating a a very
i don't want to say healthy relationship
because it's not a healthy workplace
relationship however it's healthy in so
far as it doesn't
deviate into the romantic um that
at the same time i recognize that i'd
say half of the comments that we get are
when are poppy and i ain't gonna get
shared because people really want it i
just feel like people they want the
characters for as deplorable as they can
be if you're investing your time and
effort and energy and watching the show
then you love them to a certain extent
and you want them to be happy and so you
think oh they belong together and i do
believe that i and poppy belong together
in the same way that i believe that the
characters of sunny belong together
um because but the difference with them
is that no one else will be friends with
them
and with with iron and poppy i mean
you've seen my friends in the hallway
the comedy store i would yeah sure so
like
i guess i just feel like
that we'll continue to explore that
relationship and i don't know where it's
it's going to where it's going to go
but i do understand
like our our original intention it
continues to be our intention is to is
to is to demonstrate something else yeah
and then we'll see but people truly want
them to fuck and i i also think it's
creepy because i'm like
16 years older than her yeah well it's
also kind of like a mentor-ish
relationship you know but yeah it's so
fascinating to me because um in my
experience when i'm working on shows and
you have an actor a writer that you're
like super connected you know with and
you're like this is an ephemeral i'm
just in love with the show i'm in love
with your brain and if i do this i'm
just gonna blow this whole thing up you
know it's just it's um it's what sex i
mean look sex appeal and sex drive and
and
it's i mean why do we want to fuck in
the first place yeah but just a
biological imperative for money and also
there's lots of different reasons
certainly in this in this to earn love
sure which is how love is earned sure
to yeah so can i we're talking about
like sort of a toxic workplace for a
second which you sort of alluded to i
first of all have one question which is
um i'm asking a couple of very specific
questions okay uh first of all megan
ganz was the episode about women in uh
you know video gaming the uh episode
where you know uh poppy had to give the
speech and all that i
could not believe how cathartic it was
to watch that because uh there's such a
perfect critique on this moment it was
really important to us to have
that scene with david yeah and her where
she's saying
you're you're going to that yeah like to
show how powerful women are i'm making
you do something and you're not allowed
to say no right exactly for us the way
that we wanted to
subvert expectation was to have and
ultimately be funny and i think
ultimately be a little bit more um
effective was that
uh at the end of the day
she is triumphant
but that she's triumphant because ayan
did really write that for her because we
also and again what we try to do is be
as honest as possible and to be as
authentic as possible and to not virtue
signal at all so to me
it would have been a loss and it would
have been less effective
if she went up there and just crushed on
her own because
we're presenting a character who is not
good at that right the whole point of
poppy is that why
is that she's good at at her job she
doesn't have to be good at this other
thing but now she's being asked to be
good at this other thing that this guy
ian happens to be good at and that's his
thing so if she's then good
at his thing too we just felt like that
felt false in the same way that if ayan
was really good at programming all of a
sudden then he wouldn't need her and i
think that what we're trying to explore
is like
that people are good at certain things
and what they need to
and and and what they need to be good at
to to facilitate their particular
position their their job
isn't necessarily to be able to get up
in front of a large group of people and
perform right which has historically
been something that is easier for a
person like ayan a man a white man who
has had experience after experience
whether it's conscious or unconscious
from the time he's born where he's told
you deserve a place up on that stage
talking to people everyone wants to hear
you exactly so that so that all of a
sudden of course he's i mean he of
course he's good at that she shouldn't
be good at that right because she has
historically not had the same experience
as as he had no she could get good at
that over time
or maybe she doesn't yeah either way
that doesn't make her a better
programmer so then why should that be
celebrated right right right so all that
is to say the idea that he then wrote
that speech for her is really important
because she then was able to subvert it
again by manipulating him into getting
what she wanted so we're constantly
trying to like play with um the various
uh aspects of these like weird workplace
dynamics and what we're talking about
now and then explore them and then
subvert them so this leads me into my
question about i am um and i remember in
the first episode being like i hope his
friend his name is ian it's ian it's got
to be and he fucking went with that like
i just let that made me so happy um just
little tiny things like that that these
the devils in the details with all of
your work like the tiniest little things
i get so excited about like um in the
episode where uh
hr and rachel were walking back from the
car
uh in the parking lot it was like kind
of the first parking lot uh scene i
think i had seen outside maybe and an
extra a white guy just walked right
through them who did what who did that
yeah those are the kinds of things that
we're always talking about like really
sitting on set and working with we have
an incredible uh incredible um
bench of of of directors and then also
the writers like i encourage everybody
to be on set and throw in different
ideas and then we have people from the
video game companies there it's a really
f free
environment because i i really like the
idea of like
hearing from everybody's perspective and
of course like pushing things forward at
the same time and so i can't remember
exactly who pitched that specific thing
but those kinds of details are popping
up all the time but by the way that's
the kind of shit that i wouldn't know
right i would be like oh well no he's
just walking so let's just have somebody
walk by and then somebody else probably
megan
no this motherfucker would walk straight
through and they're invisible to him
they're invisible it's a person of color
lgbtq person invisible walks right
through kind of knocks rachel over and
in order to do that you're adding time
to your day reset the ambition like it
was
so intentional and so powerful with
being completely non-verbal yeah yeah
and those are the kinds of things that
we're always talking about and that's
what's so fun about it for me
because i've been doing this a long time
and so like why am i why am i still
doing it what's like so fun for me and
truly
it's because i get to go in and you know
we have writers who and people who i
work with who are
i'm one of the oldest people now at this
point so
so crazy i know it's wild it's like
people in their early 20s you know in
our on our writing staff and then people
in their early 30s and late 30s and so
it's like whatever my generation is i
guess i guess generation x tail end of
it and then the millennials and now gen
z and so everybody's navigating the
world in a different way has never heard
of us they think i'm john rivers well
this is what's so fun is because for
years it was like when i was hiring
millennials to come in they were like
hey old man like this is the way that
things you know are
are trending right this is what we're
talking about you're calling me yella
and i and i love that because i'm like
great
that's your birthright like you're the
young generation is going to change the
culture great so i never want to be that
old man who's like talking about how
this generation is the one that fucked
it up because but i also think we talk a
lot about like sexism and
oh i thought i was gonna get shot in
that we talk about sexism we talk about
obviously racism all the important stuff
um homophobia et cetera transphobia we
don't talk a lot about ageism though
yeah and i know it's kind of to go like
old white guys give him a break that's
not what i'm trying to do i'm just
trying to say we we tend to kind of just
throw old people into uh
you know they have all this interesting
wisdom that's why i love the the ccw the
cw character so much it's like no one
even wants to hear from him he's got all
this so to me when really i start
working with really young people in
benson i go through this a lot where i'm
just like i understand but i was you
once too yeah i once thought i was going
to clean up all the oceans and i've been
around long enough knowing that that's
not the way to do it this is the way to
actually have an impact so just
i'm i'm not
like yeah i have some things to teach
you but these are the things that we
explore so then gen z now in the last
four years have entered the workforce
and it's really fun to watch the
millennials it's really fun to not be
able to text them after six it's fun to
watch the millennials don't you miss
working weekends
it's so like i didn't it was so toxic i
didn't even realize it yeah i
i i actually used to love working
weekends and then when i had kids like
yeah but but the it's fun to watch the
gen z the millennials have to
they they hear what the gen ziers are
talking about and they're like wait no
no like we're the young ones and i'm
like laughing because i'm like
it's all it's watching them now having
to navigate a younger generation and
then gen z is going to have to now
because i think it's it's tighter the
generations aren't going to be 10 20
years apart it's gonna be well that's
what yeah it's going to be like two
years someone who's 22 and 25 yes the 22
year old already has some new apps this
one doesn't even know about sure and
what's so fun for for me and all of us
like in the room is again we're navi
nobody very rarely is somebody wholly
right or wholly wrong so what we're
trying to figure out is okay
like you said where is it that that iron
or me for for for that matter a 44 or 44
year old man and you know who's who's
engaging in i wouldn't say an argument
but like a a a constructive
criticism on the way a 22 year old is
navigating her life
and then where am i crossing a line to
where i am like either mansplaining or
dadsplaining or whatever it is or
imparting wisdom that they're right and
so and then where are they getting it
right and where are they getting it
wrong these are the things that we're
constantly talking about and what we're
trying to put into the show and that's
what's so fun about it for us i was
trying to work on a bit about
mansplaining uh
and
i did put self tanner on last night and
i look insane do i look insane no okay i
was thinking when i just almost knocked
this i look like i'm in latina face am i
gonna get canceled i really hope i don't
have to shoot this because i have on
sally hansen self tanner this is not
what i look like at all look that's a
real color in my skin
it's not uncomfortable uh no i mean
you've made it uncomfortable okay
it wasn't uncovered that's my brand but
um the only reason i'm uncomfortable is
because which is
i mean i'm slightly uncomfortable is
because i feel like well no i want to do
i want this to be entertaining and i
feel like sometimes i
like when i listen to your podcast
you're laughing a lot and so are the
guests and so
yeah and when i have sex i'm having
orgasms i'm not sure but
i i don't know if people tune in
to your podcast to hear people like
pontificate about television writing
that's what i'm afraid this is so
interesting because i didn't start a
podcast i was like the last person that
started a podcast it was like completely
against my will i was like i don't know
how to just talk for two three hours i
need to write something down practice it
rehearse it rewrite it i mean for stand
up you have eight months to practice it
this whole thing and we just like go out
and start randomly like having i'm not
that funny in person you know like i
kind of been a serious person so i but i
think it's i finally realized people
just want to hear
what you have to say it doesn't matter
how you're saying it yeah i one of the
things that i hear more often than not
once people once unless i meet somebody
and they feel comfortable enough with me
yeah
one of the first things they'll say
about me is that i thought you'd be
funnier they're like you're funny on the
show but you're not funny in real life
and i yeah i think that's accurate yeah
well okay when i meet doctors i'm not
like i thought you'd be covered in blood
we're at this party like that's not i
i've accepted it it's not something
because i i i don't know maybe i but
it's part of why i if i may it is all uh
it is also i believe why you're such a
fucking incredible actor shit sorry we
just got demonetized um but uh we can't
curse because we can't by the way i
didn't notice that i don't care rating
clean i was like wait a second whitney
has a podcast
the ones i was listening to at least the
subject matters no i'm the new dave
coulier
i'm a christian comic now okay um where
was i going where was i going oh
when i watch you act it blows and i know
you guys crack up but you know after
takes and stuff but you play things so
straight and especially with iron it
that i feel like your demeanor and
essence as a person is part of why you
can play because that's my favorite kind
of comedy the niels then um leslie
nielsen like he was a leslie nielsen was
a drama actor you know john goodman was
in play like i think someone that has a
serious personality is always the
funniest
i i mean i'm just like trying to steal
as much as i can from the people who i
think are the funniest and so can i ask
who
like who growing up like who did you
watch and like the first mine was i'll
give you a second to thank mine was um
uh uh three's company
married with children martin
best yeah well classics yeah but we're
so i'm a little older than you i think
but i'm but i was we're watching tv at
the same time so
um i
i would say that i never intended to get
into comedy like legitimately and i was
when i even first started acting i was
just going out for drama stuff and then
comedies i started auditioning for
comedies and never get getting any of
those roles
um
but then but then i would meet people
like charlie day and be like well i'm
never gonna get a job with this fucking
guy's out here and
and and then like if caitlin's obviously
i'm not going off for the same parts as
caitlyn but she's legitimately
an unbelievably funny person as is glenn
danny who's just naturally funny um and
so i that was never my glenn was
juilliard actor wasn't
yeah but for right off the bat he
started booking every audition he went
out for because he can make something
real and funny yeah and then and then i
was sort of like in the beginning
learning from them i just wanted to work
so i just wrote something that i thought
was really dark and funny to me and then
they really made it funny and then i was
just holding on for dear life but when i
see somebody like
um
you know you see somebody like will
ferrell right you're like well
you're just born like that i no one's
gonna but he's playing everything pretty
straight yes also a person who's not
funny in real life exactly even though
you look into his eyes and that's always
kind of funny
thing first time i met steve carrell's
sweetheart and i was just like what yeah
you know and will's really shy yes and
not he doesn't he's not there to perform
no no no and so you walk away going wow
what a sweet man
but you're not thinking oh that's the
fuck but also what you're doing now is
making me look up to even more because
you're uh it's taking me so long to not
always like be on and always have to
like be a clown and impress people and
be funny all the time you know it it's
actually a joy for me i mean i i don't
you know i have people on that aren't
funny all the time i had bird christian
i had bobby leon
i had regressions i'm joking
[Laughter]
we now interrupt
me talking to rob to talk about stitch
fix
emily before we talk about stitch fix
i'm going rogue here oh god i would like
to address the fact that people think i
have three assistants i do not will you
tell people what your job is
i am well do you tell me what my job is
you're my caretaker and uh emotional
support system i have a vest yes
and grace is
our chief of staff here you are the
showrunner yes and
i just so we're about to talk about
grace struggling to find me clothes for
my
press events right right right and i
remember this because as when i was your
assistant you would get your looks
together wardrobe together but you know
what i'm realizing what i'm realizing is
that
both you grace and benton have all been
and in an assistant position at some
point yes and the main focus of that job
is just to get me
close that i can wear
that have horses on them that i don't
sweat in
yes that's the main job i was actually
in the job description and i heard there
have been some issues grace is having
issues yes and i i want you to watch
this video because i think it'll give
you a good idea of what what she's
dealing with huh okay
okay whitney's got a big event tonight
and i don't know what to send her out
the door in because all she owns is
horse shirts horse blazers she
definitely bought on final sale
horse dresses that are the color of uh
cat's puke
black and white horse dresses to emulate
fashion icon john wayne got into page
six
horse pants i forgot about that abstract
horses
horse cape patterned horses pasture more
horses that's my comedy shirt horse is
in motion okay she's officially lost it
i can't hide the fact that she made
another worst dressed list from her so i
don't know what to do
jesus okay um
oh new stitch fix box just came in i
mean there has to be something in here
that you can wear
this is promising oh this blue will look
so good with her blue eyeliner that she
always wears the fabric's not gonna
wrinkle for when she inevitably decides
to sit in someone's lap
okay i'm just gonna find an incinerator
for this and uh
i'm still gonna have to let her wear
like a horse necklace or horse earrings
or like horse sneakers but
honestly stitch fix truly saved the day
with this one she's gonna be dressed
like
a normal person that's stitch fix i love
you okay yes i have a horse shirt
addiction and something happens when you
think you look good in something where
you just keep buying the same thing so
stitch fix
did send this it is a beautiful it is
like a royal blue dress that i never
would have picked out myself
that is it's almost like half meghan
markle half the other one oh okay megan
middleton kate middleton middleton
i wouldn't have thought to buy this
myself so like stitch fix did did nail
it right and can i tell you this stitch
fix will you explain what the what they
do okay yes as i'm pulling out the cute
stuff they sent us so stitch fix offers
clothing hand selected by expert stylist
for your unique size style and budget
you try on pieces at home before you buy
you keep what you love and you return
what you don't and i know what you're
going to say right now what that i'm
saying it like an ad
i was just thinking about it but i
didn't i thought it and then i said
don't say that well as i was saying it i
said because when you talk to me you're
like hi and then when you're talking
about stitch fix you're like stitch
facts
you turn it i just want i want our
sponsors to know that we're taking this
seriously i know and you're trying to
talk as cute as these tops are so here's
what's amazing about stitch fix i was
worried because i was like okay you know
because you do take a quiz that you know
i was worried that the quiz was going to
make them send me ugly clothes
like horse clothes so you cheated
but stitch fix they obviously um they
will not let you be left your own
devices like something happened in the
quiz where they were like we're not
going to send you that right right um
because that's what you would wear you
know better yeah the whole point is
we're going to buy you things that you
wouldn't think to buy uh to buy but this
can i tell you they sent me this rails
plaid shirt i wear these rails plaid
shirts all of the time and they sent me
the one i don't have they must watch the
show but it is the cutest one that is
the cute i love this because i always
buy like dark colors black navy and they
sent me this sort of like um it's pink
and kind of like a soft teal yeah i've
never even seen this one no i haven't
either they sent me the better version
of something i already like
yeah yeah i know that's so cute and then
this is something they sent it's this
floral top i would never think to buy
this but it is so cute because whenever
i have like an important meeting i have
like vintage t-shirts
and our merch and that's it so this is
like a very good like zoom meeting shirt
i'll take that so stitch fix sends you
stuff that you can't be tacky it will
not let you be tacky or trashy no matter
how hard you try they will not send you
stuff that's going to embarrass you at
the barbecue so for them get started
today at stitchfix.com whitney you'll
get 25 percent off when you keep
everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com i wouldn't return any of
that no i wouldn't either i mean you're
going to keep all that
i'm not going to be able to because
you're going to take it all
stitchfix.com whitney for 25 off when
you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
whitney
it says i know
so as you all know betterhelp is one of
our sponsors and as you probably assume
emily basically keeps them in business
i use our promo code i personally love
it would be so dark if you didn't just
to like prove a point
to not give you the credit
like if you're like i'm not gonna i'm
just gonna pay the extra and not use
promo code whitney because i'm not
codependent
i love therapy we all know this i talk
about a lot you know i talk about
ancestral trauma i talk about psychology
i talk about all the work i've done on
myself
the only thing that i feel like we can
improve in therapy in general is that
when someone goes to therapy the
therapist is only hearing
the patient side of the story
you know like yeah you know what i'm
saying like you're not here like i
when my boyfriend goes to couples
therapy i kind of want to be like well
you're not going to tell him all the
things he needs to hear because you
don't think you did anything wrong right
so you know so i'm at the point where i
feel like i've so dissolved my ego and
i'm i don't take criticism as personal
attacks like i can receive feedback
without
feeling attacked without taking it
personally i'm i feel like i'm
enlightened at this point and i i want
to get to take my therapy to the next
level i want to give my employees a
chance to weigh in i wanted grace and
emily to let me know what you think i
should relay to my therapist like what
my blind spots might be like what i need
to work on
do you have any
thoughts
dude my but i want to give my boss
yeah let me know
like what are my flaws what should i
work on in therapy in your opinion oh
do you have it
i think come on this is a safe space
let's go let's go
there was that thing you'd
texted about the other day oh what was
it no yeah tell her i know the guy what
was it no remember
wait you guys text without me on no no
you know what it was it was a voicemail
it's gone okay it's in the void oh but
you did you just forgot what you said
yeah it was just the other day i you
know one too many june shines okay all
right it's on the job it might be that
i'm gonna just write that down in mind
it might have been that you were a great
boss
like you're you're almost you're not i
know
i'm intimidating yeah it's so i should
present myself as more flawed to make
you feel comfortable that feels
co-dependent
like i if i'm you know what i'm saying i
can't you know what they say when you
get healthy the sick get angry
right that's us we are the sick ones
yeah i am enraged i i know that my
perfect mental health is probably
upsetting and intimidating i get that
but look at me more of an inspiration a
paragon well you know what now that you
know what that means
do you have anything else to say
i don't think that i
really
have anything else to ask you yeah these
are our are us problems final final
opportunity to tell me things i need to
work on about myself in therapy anything
else
grace i'm scared i'm it's a trap nothing
i'm terrified okay i mean look i'm gonna
still go to therapy i'm still gonna go
because even when you don't think you
have anything to work on there's still
something to work on there's still
something there
there's still something there
you want to have people in your life
give you feedback but you want a real
professional licensed therapist to help
you navigate right normally neural
pathways so they need way more better
help than i do at this point right
because
i mean being around me we need best help
it must you need the best we need the
best and that is at better health well
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today the service is
available for clients worldwide and you
can start communicating with a licensed
therapist i don't need it in under 48
hours
thank god i'm done i'm calling mine
right now i graduated they were like you
know what you're good you don't even
need to see us anymore you graduated out
of better health
that's great this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and good for you listeners
get ten percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com whitney
so you know what i'm realizing it's my
job to make you laugh and make you
funnier that's my worth that's my only
worth in this world um when did you
start when when when when did you
recognize that you were funny when i
moved to la i was here for like a year
oh really yes
yeah auditioning what was the intention
dramatic actor or dramatic actress well
i had gotten a job
uh on that show punk'd
uh with ashton kaitlyn too and yeah oh
that's
crazy i always forget about that because
she's just done so i know her so many
others i mean that that and that's
launched a bunch of people's yes dax was
yeah the first season and bj novak was
actually on the first season and so i
auditioned for that i went in to
audition to be like a vj like in new
york they asked me to come be a vj a
couple times when i was in philadelphia
in college
i uh worked at qvc and king of prussia
mall i was a model for pantyhose and i
would walk around and wear
that i paid for college and then uh
there was a place called banyan
productions based in philadelphia yeah
they did extreme home makeover yeah and
all those i was the person that had to
be anyone in the auditions because i was
like i'm studying as an actress so i
would be like the host and then i would
be the builder then i would be like the
person that was coming to see the house
and i would be the painting lady or
whatever and i'd have to switch roles
and improvise with them and
that uh an agent saw me do that set my
tape and then i went and i was like
auditioning for uh like to be a vj
remember that job you're just like hey
guys what's going on
and daisy funtes is uh a gangster i love
her but it wasn't for me she's got a
very successful she's got it that's
right i cannot stop talking about daisy
fuentes it's so wild and um and
i came in and i was just being i guess
too ridiculous and they were like this
isn't for you but we have this show
called punkt that we'd love for you to
audition for which is basically like you
seem like a really good liar and like
you have nothing to lose and possibly a
psychopath and then i came out my
audition for that and i went to that
downtown mtv the one on colorado used to
be there went into audition for an
unknown project with ashton kutcher
because well this was the secret season
remember he canceled it publicly and
then there was a secret season so we
didn't really know what we were
auditioning for i showed up jason
goldberg who was his partner at the time
maybe still
who's pretty scary i mean he's this tall
guy he's really smart he comes out and i
looked at the um i paid the meter and i
only had a couple quarters i had like
seven dollars at the time i didn't have
any money and i looked at it it was like
a cattle call you know when you would go
to auditions and it just you know odds
bring omnipop don buckwald i didn't have
any of them and i looked at it and i was
like oh i just can't i can't afford to
sit here for i mean there's all these
models there's just people over there so
i left and jason saw me leave he saw me
look at it and leave and he's like hey
just something about the not giving a
shit
or not
that psychology of like i accidentally
did a you know play hard to get he was
like come here and then i went and sat
in and we did these improvs and it was
him ashton was not there
all he wanted me to do was he was like
i'm going to insult you for as long as i
can and let's see how much you he just
was trying to see what you did when you
were scared he was just trying to scare
you as much as possible and i was like
dude i grew up in an alcoholic home with
borderline personality family members
like
let's fucking do this you know what i
mean like there was a one thing i really
could do was just keep going back at him
insulting him insulting him and then
because i was seeing people coming out
crying
you know and i was like oh i'm dead
inside like we can do this all day and
then there was a couple things where he
was like figure out a way in this next
improv for me to un-buckle your belt
looking back with the me too stuff i
know why it sounds weird but that's not
what he was doing he was trying to get
it so he would take off my belt i had to
make a realistic situation where that
would be a good solution and so we like
did stuff like that and then i got the
job that way
but so but so then when was the
transition where you were like oh i oh
when i was in l.a i would go to like see
my friends and i would tell these
stories about things that had happened
to me or i would just say my opinions
about real things and they would laugh
and i was like this isn't funny i'm
serious like i seriously just got towed
and
and so they would laugh when i was
serious and they're like you're funny
and i was like no i'm a serious person
you mentioned that you're from an
alcoholic home both parents uh addiction
in both and did you find that you had to
manage a lot of situations yeah i'm
almost 15 years in elena
yeah which is adult or adult child about
colics which is the 12-step program you
go to to you know not micromanage uh
mother
uh
stop letting him interview you
stop letting him interview you i know
i'm like i really like this interview
have you talked about this kind of stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah i've talked about
okay i talked about a bunch i mean the
main thing is i just haven't talked to
you about i know because we i we are i
want to talk to you we're not fully just
maybe it's not here i would i would i
would say that uh my favorite parts of
say
you know when listening to howard stern
for example or listening to dax even
you know the you want i want to hear
from the person whose podcast it is but
that's just me that is so interesting
but i think also we have not hung out we
haven't hung out we're like catching up
on each other
one of the things that we're exploring
in in mythic quest that we're going to
continue to explore if we do more
seasons which it looks like we are um
is why we are who we are so and what
nature that's nurture yeah and what led
us to to to become the human beings that
we are specifically creative people
and what we what we have the ability to
let go of what should we let go of
because that's a scary thing i think for
people especially in terms of you know
the
essentially like the armor that you
built and all the weapons the emotional
weapons and tools that you were able to
build for yourself as a child that are
no longer necessary that are now
obsolete you know i used to walk into
rooms like like i'm gonna embarrass
myself before you can embarrass me i'm
gonna you know i can feel you falling
out of love with me so i'm just gonna
all the tools that served us really well
when we were kids being anxious around
narcissists etc etc and which ones are
liability and which ones are actually
still kind of useful and which ones are
inherited and which ones are socially
constructed and or passed on yeah and
one of the things you can hold on to
that will allow you to still continue to
create what you create and be the person
and the artist that you are but not
destroy yourself in the process love it
because i was um i went to dr david agus
for something after he was on the
podcast and he's just this brilliant um
doctor you guys like it's like a famous
he's on tv all the time talking about
covet like like fact checking all the
alex jones stuff and uh he i went down
to his office and i did have a weird bee
in my bonnet about people being like i
have anxiety i have anxiety and i was
like well of course you do you're on a
ball flying through space that's
on fire half the time and there's like
we should be a little bit anxious you
know we it's it's only in the last like
whatever 150 years that we're in
buildings with doormen like you know in
the world scary anything else would be
denial but obviously people have anxiety
disorders can't get out of their bed i
have you know family members like that
so i've seen that but i went down to his
office and i had recently gone on prozac
because i just had this thing where
i like that i beat myself up and
critique myself that's how i'm supposed
to i make something good i'm not gonna
be like i love myself and i'm the best
and then go charge people 60 to see
something that's
hasn't been
critiqued and made better you know i
think that serves me really well um
and uh
i went down to his office and i was like
okay so i just i'm having some like
anxiety and i just sometimes like i just
can't focus like my brain's here and i'm
like i have this idea for this joke but
then i like put down the script and then
sometimes if i'm an audition i'll sort
of think i'll want to improvise a joke
but it's a scripted show don't improvise
and he was like is any of this
like not working for you
and i was like
i guess it does kind of what drives me i
guess you're right he's like do you want
to change that about yourself like do
you want to do worse stand up because
you you know are so proud and have such
high self-esteem about anything you put
down so it really made me stop um
over pathologizing stuff like that
like this is why i this is my magic
potion like these are my superpowers
they're not my limitations
can i ask one more question that i won't
ask any questions
oh it's not for me it's for the
listeners
i think i think the list i'm interested
in this i'm going back to the this is
your show but i'm going back to my own
instincts and you're saying if i'm
interested in it then i think that the
listener will be interested unless
you've already covered this
ad nauseam not which i don't know i
listen to a bunch of your podcasts that
i feel like you don't not with someone
like you though because you and i are i
think pretty similar but i think the
interesting part and i because i want to
get to ian and that is that we were
earlier before we walked in here and uh
you're welcome for not saying save it
you know that when you read a podcast
yeah you're like we mostly talked about
your house there's nothing really to say
and uh um the toxic work environment
that is mq i really want to deconstruct
because i do believe everyone's
superpowers in that office are probably
things that most people would go like i
need to get that i need to change that
about myself and but a lot of the things
that make things toxic
toxic quote-unquote because we also have
such a um low bar now for what is toxic
and what is hard and what is
uncomfortable you know i think it's
important that people are able to be
uncomfortable in situations and if you
don't like your body no one likes the
ross i don't know what to tell you and
someone that has a superpower you know
as comedians i remember eric zicklin
said this once uh when i was doing a tv
show that i was running at a very young
age and i kind of didn't realize it's
just a lot of like math and sitting in
meetings and knowing like how to
add numbers in your head super fast and
you know i was just kind of sitting
there acting like a showrunner is really
what i was doing and um just like
nodding and being like yeah it should it
should probably be the blue couch
because what if it looks weird on camera
like i would just say things that i
thought showrunner said
and um
as eric sicklin said this once he was
like because he's been on so he was on
frasier he's been on so many shows uh
with comedians that got their own show
and he's like it's basically like
network saying you're really creative
and hilarious now come run a 7-eleven
like you don't have a skill set for that
which is part of the reason you can be
so creative you can be so creative
because you don't follow rules and
you're not thinking about people's
feelings all the time even though you
have really big feelings and you have to
focus on the big picture you have to
keep people moving you have to have such
a passion but now that's interpreted to
some people as like toxic and it's like
well if this person isn't a little bit
erratic or different and not constantly
thinking about your feelings like this
thing's not going to get made yeah when
do we when do we allow and when do we go
aside racism sexism and sexual that's
not what i'm talking about i'm talking
about just general
disagreeing with people in a workplace
now feels like an attack well yeah i
mean the i these are the exact things
that we're talking about all the time
and that's
and and things are constantly evolving
and changing but i think i think what it
what it really comes back to
all the time is the thing is something
you mentioned earlier which is like you
know it when you see it so for example
we we discuss this all the time um
meg can come in and she can be wearing
uh a really cute top right and i'm like
oh maggie you look cute today right and
i'm very cognizant of when i would say
that how i would say that
if i would say that what our
relationship is
i've known her for 10 years we've been
friends like and there's a context and
there's also just simply a way that it's
being presented
someone else could come in said the same
exact thing and she could be 100 totally
creeped out about that right and then
the argument of the third party moron
would say well there's a double standard
right why does somebody get to do this
one thing and this other guy doesn't get
to do this other thing and it's
literally the same thing yep and you're
basically relying on some sort of sixth
sense or a lizard brain thing or
whatever it is but we're human beings
and that's a part of what it is it's not
math that we have to trust our instincts
and that like you said you've navigated
a good portion of your life recognizing
that like oh this situation is creeping
me out this guy's a creep and i know i
need to get away from him and those are
the kinds of things that are like
dicey i'm obsessed with that shit i'm
obsessed with it the book the gift of
fear by gavin to becker is um which
every every man should read it too about
how to trust your gut as a woman because
the number and i know i talk about this
a lot you guys but i think you would
love this um whenever women are
sexually assaulted abused attacked uh 99
of them in the interview afterwards with
the police the other one percent they is
we didn't say they didn't do this they
were just too traumatized and they
couldn't interview them they were just
too upset and uh they always say i knew
there was something off about that guy i
just i knew it he did all the right
things he carried my groceries he called
me ma'am he offered to hold the door but
i just i knew something was off and
that's always my stuff with security is
whenever like a a big dude or like a
howard stern fan was like bubba booty
and like comes up to me and tries to
touch me and security i'll try i'm like
no i promise this yeah this guy's okay
yeah i'm worried about that guy in the
corner that's not trying to get my
attention with just something i don't
know he well that's skinny i'm telling
you that's the one and i can't even
explain why you just have to trust me
yeah yeah and so so that's exactly what
we're what we're talking about uh
in the show which is um we have to try
to continually find whatever those lines
are of what is acceptable and what's
unacceptable both in a workplace
environment and just in a in a social
environment right and it's just going to
keep evolving and keep changing and then
certain things will resonate with the
culture and we'll say oh yeah that's
fucked up i can't believe that was ever
like a possibility yeah it's like when
i'm when i i remember the when this all
the mewtwo stuff was hitting hollywood
and all the male age it's really oh we
can't even hug a woman at work anymore
and it was like
you you never could yeah like that's
that was never
something that was appropriate like your
assistant don't hug her totally and and
i
i i get that argument quite a bit with
people thinking that i'm going to
commiserate with them which is like oh
man we can't even like make jokes about
this or whatever anymore and i'm like
well
no
but but also like
there's no i truly believe there's not
an attack on
comedy i i just don't think there is i
think what it's forcing people to do
is to uh dig a little bit deeper and
maybe get a little bit more specific and
level up be more thoughtful about it be
more artful about it that's all it's
just simple it's a gift to comedians
it's weeding out the hacks i keep going
in his coverage and my you might keep
drifting off to the
like dare you why that's weird because
you're
unconsciously grabbing it always white
men constantly mansplaining unbelievable
really quick on mansplaining remember i
was trying to write that bit about
mansplaining where i was like please
mansplain to me you have all the
information
who's gonna tell me otherwise but then
someone's like mansplaining it's more if
you already know something and a guy
explains it to you
but
i don't i just i i was like let's not be
so proud that we don't get the
information from the men on how to do
the thing ourselves because they they
know how to do it we don't okay so
that's a good example of something that
i'm i have to learn how to navigate
right because i've been in a position of
power for a long time running these tv
shows and yet i have people who work for
me uh younger people both men and women
who uh
who are coming up through the ranks and
i have to be very respectful of the fact
that sometimes
they either want to hear my opinion of
how i would navigate a situation and
sometimes they don't and the the easiest
way to know is whether or not they
fucking ask so if you're not asking me
yep yep then i'm not gonna have to offer
the information and if they want to know
they'll ask this generation does not
lack 100 or if i get a sense that
someone is a little bit reticent to ask
for whatever reason it might be i might
i might pick a time where i can find
them and say hey i just noticed you were
interested in this is there anything you
want to discuss or anything you want to
talk about about this maybe i can
i can
i'd do that
i didn't remember when i sat down at
what point did i say you know sitting
down uh and uh what were we talking
about how what shows make money and why
i remember i was like giving that speech
and it was so funny because ben
like younger generation sees things in
such a different way i was like no no
like the syndication thing that that
ship might have sailed but this is what
happens you get points you never give up
your points you get an ep credit we
don't make you know as much and we're
talking about movies and you don't make
as much for movies but if big movie
stars they make a lot of their money on
like the campaigns you get otherwise so
when people want to go like women in
hollywood don't make as much agree of
course but also
they get to make a ton of money from
lancome and chanel and all these other
things that guys can't do i mean you can
george clooney can do his watch ads in
china or whatever but it's like there's
other ways to make money as women just
having a having the gross conversation
like having the discomf and the
uncomfortable conversation but i believe
you can have those uncomfortable
conversations but it depends on how
things are framed again like in a
writer's room it's a it's it's
considered a safe space to have
difficult conversations yeah that still
doesn't mean that anybody can walk in
and just be a few abusive or make a like
a straight-up racist joke and say well
no i'm in a writer's room therefore i'm
protected no no no no um so those days
are however there is a way to frame as
in everything in life frame a
conversation by saying okay
i recognize that this is dicey i have a
question about it and i want do i have
your permission to to allow for maybe
something that might come across as
racist because i s or
misogynistic or homophobic or whatever
it might be because i truly have a blind
spot and i want to understand
because i yes i want to become a better
person but also because it actually
makes the work better and makes the show
more interesting because it's layered
with another person's point of view you
can frame things that way and what you
find is that human beings rise to the
occasion they recognize what you it is
that you're trying to do and then we're
all working in communion with one
another to make whatever decision we are
we we make to to progress the story but
i'm also not asking some random person
on the street to get their emotional
labor i'm not like hey you're black can
you explain something to me and give me
your your time i mean you are getting
paid like it's i hired you because i
want your brain i want your point of
view i want to learn from you also you
know we want your voice in the show so
if i i kind of like feel weird about
walking on eggshells about asking
someone something if that's their job
too right now and so so one like why am
i asking you to do your job right now
and why do i am i worried about getting
in trouble totally but i think that
people okay so i'll give you an example
so one thing that we
this this interesting line that we have
to navigate or at least i have to
navigate is you know you hire okay on
mythicquest we have a young
gay
black woman who grew up in l.a yes right
now i can write funny shit and i can
write interesting story lines and i know
the things that um connect us all as
human beings however i can't get
specific
enough to create a really well-rounded
character right
so the only person that truly can
is a young sinbad
well if he was available
he's he's funny i've had sinbad on on
sunday i had
if you need to know anything about
windbreakers he's the guy
that's right that's right
but so so
we went out looking and we found a young
gay black woman who grew up in la right
nice so then you have her in the room
but then i was she wasn't even a writer
i was having a coffee shop
she uh i love hiring non-writers too by
the way she wasn't a writer actually she
was a teacher in my kid's school well
she
was a writer but that's a whole
different story she was she had a
graduate degree but was teaching and
then
her the degree was in comedy writing it
was
quite fortuitous anyway the point is
then then she's in the room and i have
to make sure and i had a very honest
conversation with her which was
look
i brought you in to be to deliver this
particular point of view
but not only because of that right
because i need someone who's funny and
someone i want to spend time with and
somebody who i think can progress all
elements of the story and the human
condition
further but yes i have to be honest that
i'm also bringing you in for this
specific reason it would be like saying
hey i'm bringing megan to write for the
women so what i do is i write for the
men and she writes for the women what
the fuck is that right it's silly
however there is some truth to the fact
that i'm also bringing in meg to write
for the women because i can't deliver
that point of view again and it's not
just dialogue it's also how the
situation would go down exactly so third
party moron looks at that and goes well
that's a double standard what you're
saying is you are bringing her into
right for women but also not and i'm
like well you're a fucking moron who are
you who are these people you're talking
about the q a awards yeah it's when you
hear yeah when you hear criticism of of
whatever but i don't think anybody that
doesn't make television should weigh in
that's my whole thing sure you just
shouldn't you don't know you're not here
you don't know how it works you don't
unders like to me i always i had this
theory when um i got like trashed a lot
making television and especially
multicam because i made a multi-camera
time that no one was making multicam and
all the reviews were like uh this is
canned laughter and it was like what
like what come to a show come to a show
and watch how it works and then i
discovered that the mics were under the
seats which was not ideal so it was
louder
i also then learned uh you should mix up
the jokes every time for a multi-cam
audience because as soon as they know
the punch line they're going to start
laughing like a little too soon uh
they're gonna laugh as if they've heard
the joke before uh you always want to
get so i would always do the joke i
wanted to put in the show last as like a
surprise and but the reviewers and the
critics they wouldn't have said why
don't you come see how we make this why
don't you go see the people in the
audience like you know if you haven't
made a show or made television or taken
a risk like this or even like what you
did with your 300 dollars making a pilot
stand up same thing i'm like everyone
just goes go do stand up just just to
see the level of difficulty when you
want to weigh in and say oh i didn't
like that and here's why well what i
find interesting is that there's so many
people who write about television
for a living who don't understand the
process of writing for television at all
and so and i think look that's fine
everybody has a a job in a niche and a
thing that they go to do no you're just
trolls you know it's like the is it the
oscar wilde quote i feel like he said
most of the quotes right that um critics
are the people that go where the battle
was fought and they shoot
and they shoot the survivors
well
i i haven't i happen to to think that
there is a room
for criticism like outside third party
criticism because i think it's i think
it's interesting to hear it's certainly
not an objective point of view it's a
subjective point of view but it's
somebody who's not on the inside
and then can
have at least
a learned opinion about about yeah but
you're you have a childhood you're
triggered you don't like this kind of
thing totally you're this is all your
emotions but that's a part of their job
if they're a good critic every female
critic i mean this was
you know 10 years ago when there weren't
a lot of female critics and there
weren't a lot of females on tv creating
their own shows that were like trying to
say that that the nbc show i did was
sexist it was like okay well my show
runner's a woman
this is a gender reversal where the man
is doing the uh traditionally with
female behavior the females do it like
did you watch it or oh you just don't
like me yeah and that's totally fine but
this felt like a dm sure this didn't
feel like a review
well sure get the voodoo doll of me and
just poke it instead of
of course there's the question of
who who are these people what are their
credentials but i can tell you that
there are a number of of critics whose
work i really respect and i read and i
go oh that's interesting i never thought
about it that way but they're really
good elvis mitchell always did that yeah
emily nussbaum was like to me like just
somebody who i seek out not not to to
see whether or not i want to um watch a
show or not because that's bullshit but
when i love a show or i hate a show and
she's done a a piece about it's like
asking your like coolest friend like did
you like that shit yeah should i give it
a go or like she can get you to think
about it in a way that you hadn't
thought about it before which to me is
like the best kind of like
criticism
that that said um
if i can't believe how few people um
know
that a person's name being like oh this
is written by right then they think oh
well the entire episode was written by
that one person
and then whether it's um demonization or
accolades that go to that one person
it's completely false it doesn't that
doesn't represent what the writer's room
is the writer's room is truly a
communion and confluence of so many
different people and then all put
through the grinder of the executive
producer but it's also like i remember
watching um
uh what was the one with the idris elba
where he
was uh um
help can you look up idris albert that
netflix movie he did when he played the
dictator it doesn't matter but he they
were shooting a scene where someone was
like probably 50 yards away with these
giant like like hey
bailey things how am i not married um
and i was watching i was like no one
understands how hard this scene is to
shoot no one there's an a.d that's lying
down in the field looking up this is an
audio nightmare this person is like the
the grass is hitting the mic no one can
hear each other someone's like dude you
got that like the actor has no idea what
the the uh coverage is and i was like no
one is gonna get how hard this scene is
to shoot this scene alone should get an
oscar so it's like to me it's this the
sound editor on that
like should get paid a million dollars a
minute i mean it's the kind of thing
where it's like but but people just go
okay scene and field it's like golf golf
is the hardest thing to shoot but no
one's watching golf being like wow these
dps are incredible it's like that guy's
hitting the ball but he's following the
ball which is incredibly hard to do so
to me i'm like i will never critique
a dp that shoots golf because i think
they're i know how hard that is yeah
yeah i i truly i i never i have very
strong opinions on lots of people
oh that's the name of the movie beast of
donation is the um tester that came in
to replace uh the girl when she became
the streamer based on this person
oh
no
okay
um it's based on
his
a version of his actual personality
interesting he's not really but i got it
i did kind of get it
yeah well he well i'll tell you this he
represents uh you're the character
you're talking about his name is lou yes
played by craig mason yes um craig is a
writer and i've known him for years and
he is mostly well he's worked in comedy
but he's most famous for chernobyl he
wrote chernobyl and he uh wow and so
he's a big video game guys a friend of
mine he worked a little bit on
mythicquest
and so uh we we wanted like a character
that could represent like a middle-aged
or even like older than middle-aged
white dude who had like been in this job
forever he's everywhere every guy in
every writer's room when i first started
it is
like harrowing to i mean how exactly it
is i think any waitress or any you know
woman male 1
everyone sees this everywhere is my
guess but it was just i think everyone
will see that character and has that
person in their life yeah so the great
thing about craig is that he's he's
truly like such a wonderful person that
he knows that because he's so fucking
smart
like he could be that person and he and
he isn't and yet he does tend to
um hate everybody and everything which
is something i love about him
and he's such a curmudgeon but he's such
a like teddy bear in real life like he
doesn't actually act on those impulses
but i think he wants to so i think this
was like a big release for him
but he represents like he definitely
represents the guy that you wrote yes
yes and then with the the you know
working overtime working along and all
that kind of stuff i kind of was like
okay i think i have an idea of this um
the specificity of this show again again
and we always say the more um specific
you are the more universal you are the
fact that i relate to all this so
specifically it means everybody else
will like that's that guy in my job
that's a guy in my job it's about what
it is about a writer's room yeah the
show the show is about a video game but
the reason i wanted to do the show in
the first place i didn't want to do a
show about video games i went and
visited a company and when i walked in
and they explained to me how it all
worked i was like this sounds like a
television show like the way that they
the way that they produce it and so i
just know that world and so i think it's
triggering for a lot of people who work
in the entertainment industry what
what have you learned about human nature
or yourself or um
you know just our mental evolution now
that you've been working in video games
i'm always very curious if if video
games went away tomorrow would we all
just be
would there be carnage in the street
would we would the people that play
video games
or or would that catharsis go away and
would we just be savages
would crime be rampant i don't know
however i can say that it's not a world
that i knew very much about prior to
doing the research for the show and i
can say and i think i think historically
it's just been a like a community that's
been marginalized in popular culture to
be these just like dorks who live in
their basement or whatever but it is a
global phenomenon
billions of people play games and i
think what's so and yes is there a dark
side to it i don't mean that i just mean
you know there's this thing um calcium
which is this uh uh you would love it
it's um basically uh
it's football
but mma fighting and in italy florence
yeah they do once again commander so the
the weak in florence that they do that
crime goes down to about zero i'm just
always obsessed with what are the things
we do to get stuff out of our system
you know and our video games are part of
that yeah i i think so and i'll go one
step further which is like again i tried
i tried there are so many negative
aspects to to gaming and and they're
well documented and well talked about to
me
uh what i see that's
most um heartwarming and optimistic is
the community that's based around it and
the connections that are made
by people who
have historically been looking for that
sense of community and haven't found it
in the traditional ways that we did
growing up um and you know maybe if you
weren't a very good baseball player or
couldn't do the you know you didn't feel
comfortable being on the debate team
whatever it is you had to find other
outlets but those outlets were very
isolating whereas now with online gaming
community there's a community and you
can become not only friends with people
all over the globe but you can you can
do the thing that's most important in
life i think which is to feel connected
to other human beings and that didn't
exist before and now it does and i think
there's something really great about i'm
fascinated about video games because
there's a bunch of studies that i have
them here that um kids have played
because there's this thing of video
games they're bad for kids like there
are studies that say that kids who play
video games actually have faster
reflexes in the world it's just it feels
like such an interesting thing that we
grapple with so much and i'm so and i'm
so curious because you know think about
i would i why would anyone want to spend
all their time in the real world if they
could go into some magical world you
know it's just sort of there's something
it just says more about how shitty
reality is is that everyone wants to
escape it all the time well and what you
can do what you're seeing with a lot of
those online communities too is that
they're able to create a world of their
own so yes they're playing
fill in the blank game whatever the
fucking game is yes and that's a part of
the experience but they're also
communicating with one another and the
way that they're communicating is a
sense of work is also a kind of world
building because they're now they're now
building whatever experience they want
the world to be which is really
empowering empowering especially for
kids who all day long are being told
what the fuck did what to do now they
get to be a motivational control yeah
which i mean
but just like anything else i had to
take the ipads away from my kids
and and and it has actually
um been wonderful since the ipads have
been gone because what i noticed was
they were just like it's just like
anything else you do too much of it
and you and you abuse it and you go in
the wrong direction with it or you go to
the extreme it's gonna have uh negative
consequences and that's what happened
with ipad games right and they're 10 and
9. maybe when they're 15 and 16
well they say it's very close to in the
brain like a gambling addiction because
you're always playing for that last win
so i would try to play fruit ninja i'd
be like i'm gonna play it a couple times
but then i was like well now i have to
beat my score then i got lower and i
have to prove this to myself and then it
stops being a choice so that's when it's
an addiction when it stops being a
choice and starts to feel like work
almost like the laughs almost
i'm just i'm just pointing that out i
mean i yes but i
feel the same way which is like what is
it's a level of validation
it that i'm seeking it's i don't do it
the same way that you do up on stage but
like i want people to like what i do i
want people to have a reaction to it
certainly if i'm my intention is to make
people laugh i want them to laugh
if my intentions make them cry i want
them to cry and if i don't get that
um does it does it chip away a little
bit at my soul and then what the fuck
does that mean and if so why why do i
need it so bad why do i need it so bad i
mean that's really what i'm always
experimenting with on stage was how long
can i go without making a joke and how
long can i hold a joke for the maximum
and you know if i know i have a good one
i'll wait wait wait
wait for the lap wait for the claps to
go around the laps and see if i can just
buy a little more time it's like a funny
little game to like see how
um uh okay with myself i can be without
a laugh for how long because some great
things come out of those silences too
but your profession is to me the
scariest you put yourself in a place
that no other human being really does
especially or certainly in our in our
business which is i get to i get to
work and write and then i control every
aspect of the thing and then eventually
when everything's perfect in my mind i
put it out and then it still might get
destroyed i want to do that too there's
just been a couple times where they say
they like you know wanted so i mean i've
definitely tried to do that you do it so
well you know i i i've done that
incredibly successfully oh thank you
thank you thank you did you not thank
you i don't i mean i have had a couple
pilots that have not gone since and it
was always like this is too weird this
is too like meta it's too
you know like i was having but you could
but wait a second wait the last two
pilots that i did one didn't go because
it was just uh for a litany of reasons
lisa kudrow martin short greg kinnear
thing i did for amazon and then uh this
other thing i did for hbo didn't happen
because it was just too weird it was
like i was having like fantasies where
jenna jameson was my like
like life coach they just were like
this is a lot but so you're taking your
last two
your last two projects last two pilots
which are like historically the i mean
the hardest things to do in television
and using that as an indicator of your
success in running television series
well i mean it's you keep going you've
done two yes but to do one that goes 14
is bigger than doing in my opinion
five that have gone yeah but you got you
could have you could have stayed on
broke two broke girls for as long as you
wanted and that could have gone forever
and then you could have stayed on
roseanne
but i know that
it that you launched
you launched the return of one of the
greatest shows of all time to
mass like mass appeal and also mass
critical success like that's impossible
and all the showrunners in hollywood you
were really supportive thanks so much
for being so cool during that time
when i watched it it was one of the most
progressive shows on television that
have had ever been made dj doesn't kick
i'm sorry dj doesn't kiss the black girl
in the school play then she goes to talk
to the dad or the dad comes to talk to
her remember and she locks the door of
the diner i mean that was like that was
i mean i think you're like this too in
terms of having the bravery to play a
character who is
a narcissist who is ignorant who has a
blind spot you know and she was willing
to play someone that did something
racist and ignorant you know like we
need people to go that far and be that
brave if you have someone's brain that's
that brave it's gonna show up in other
ways too you can't decide you can only
be brave in one way and then you have to
turn the thing off when you go home you
know so um
she uh
i don't know everyone just twitter the
self-righteous indignation of she's the
reason trump won or like it she always
said the reason that i
that roseanne was my favorite show is
she would always say that just because
you're poor doesn't mean you're stupid
and in hollywood that's the thing i mean
is joe blow and iowa gonna get that joke
yeah yeah they are is the guts or the
people of virginia get that yeah i have
family in virginia they're smarter than
you you're just pitching old you know
veronica's closet episodes this is gonna
probably be made with or without me i
mean it was i mean tom warner i'm sure
you know tom was you know gonna do it
sarah sarah gilbert was already involved
um john goodman already say said he was
down if john goodman's doing anything i
will do
craft services so um and then laurie
metcalf and i'm like okay great so she
did what an amazing opportunity
to reach
uh everyone you know jackie voted for
hillary she ended up panicking and
voting for jill stein and
voted for trump like let's have these
conversations because i'm seeing all
these families get torn apart because
they voted differently let's watch that
you know let's have uh um
you know sarah's son want to wear a
dress to school in elgin illinois and
the conflict so fast instead of just
going like you can do whatever you want
we're so woke being didactic to people
saying this is what you should do in
this situation it's more complicated
than that this is a man who's 65 years
old who
he's basically saying you can wear
whatever you want in the house i don't i
don't do not care but i know
how kids treat a child that looks
different i used to beat up the um
foreign exchange students
am i an irresponsible person for letting
you go to school in a dress knowing
you're gonna get your ass kicked i can't
let you your ass kicked you know so that
was such a fascinating thing that no one
had the audacity to let a character
think that way but i feel like right now
you're defending something that was
universally accepted as awesome oh yes
no it's just more that i went on i i did
like a show didn't everybody love that i
will answer more of your questions about
that later because i feel like i'm not
being funny and uh trying to not be
boring because
do you think people would find this
there was also so much so much i mean i
find this fascinating i didn't even know
that that was the case i from i'm
obviously not an outsider but it seemed
like from my point of view
it was like that went over
like gangbusters like everybody in the
industry was excited everybody in the
audience was excited so i'm sorry that
you yeah no it was just it was pretty um
it was just pretty wild i guess just at
the end of the day and it was um and
look she did say some crazy shit but
that's what we should put on tv i said
to one of the showrunners i was like so
you just think people that voted for
trump shouldn't be allowed to be
represented on television i think part
of the reason they voted that way is
because they didn't feel seen and they
felt underrepresented like why like like
all you harvard dorks like i don't know
how to tell you that
like i'm not i'm not a harvard i'm not
from i didn't go to harvard like i don't
just want to do simpsons you know super
clever jokes that only half the audience
got like i think that show was brilliant
but you know so i guess i was just um
and laurie metcalf and john goodman
don't you just want to watch this show
again i got
their big struggle speaking of
having young people on a production
uh and then older people so uh john
goodman's character dan obviously works
as a construction worker and there's
illegal undocumented workers
taking his jobs that is a very real
thing that would happen to dan in that
moment so we were like opioid addicts
that would absolutely be happening
because they can't afford to get the
surgery done so they just have to stop
the bleeding dan would be losing stuff
to undocumented workers blah blah blah
dj would be have gone to the military
that's how it would have gone and there
was a scene where
dan was telling roseanne that an
undocumented worker took her his work
and he said
uh illegals
these illegals are taking the jobs
in his private kitchen with his wife
at 65 that's what he would have said he
would have said illegals
right yes and then we go through the
rehearsal it all works and then a lot of
the younger people are like
humans can't be illegal we're like yeah
we know he doesn't know that he doesn't
read you know um all the stuff that we
read he doesn't watch the shows that we
watch like he doesn't know any of this
he's not in hollywood like well he can't
say that
and it was like well he had that's what
he would say that's the only uh word he
would really know to describe the
situation so it was a it was a really
big saga and i was in hr a lot but you
have to fight you like that's the kind
of thing i would fight through yeah you
know i don't need to fight for a joke in
the writers room that's never gonna get
it in but i will fight for the character
staying the character
and not you know especially older
characters that's what they would call
it he would say secretary yes that he
wouldn't say chief of staff he'd say
secretary yes stuff like that well and
then it just becomes a question of what
what are you then the platform becomes
what are you celebrating or what are you
not celebrating so for example
in that in that situation you're being
authentic without
celebrating necessarily what the
behavior is that god it doesn't matter
you're just presenting a real human
being yeah
i i'm it's willie lohman i mean if you
go back and watch you know it's like he
wouldn't have access to this that means
he's like on vulture every day like
trying to see who got canceled for
saying the wrong word he's just not yeah
you know so i don't know it was pretty
wild but it is um
i would consider it from
from an outsider's point of view that
was incredibly successful oh my gosh
thanks well let's talk about more of
your success because i know i have to
let you out i feel like i'm using uh
taking advantage of you oh my god don't
let your watch please i was just curious
um can you spill your water on your
watch so it's not working
i want to talk about i want to talk to
you i want to talk to you off the air
and on the air uh this isn't even the
air the psychology of men who wear rings
yes
i want to get into it
great let's get into it such a brilliant
brilliant i mean as soon as you see that
you know i know exactly who i'm dealing
with yeah i know exactly who i'm dealing
with but it to me is always such a shame
that men don't get to wear jewelry like
i'm so bummed for them you know there's
so few things you guys can do like you
you can wear a watch and that's pretty
much it
chain wallet maybe
but there's something fascinating to me
like about wearing rings because
historically it must have been about
showing wealth right it was for royals
to show off how much money they had
right yes uh
it's used like when what happens to iron
when he's putting his rings on and what
do they mean to him
um yeah so it was based on when i when i
was doing research on what who these
guys are because it's all guys um that's
changing to a certain extent but the
kind of people that are creative
directors and like to who ascend to
those positions um
they
there's like a very specific look
it's really strange
the thing that i was getting about
dorsey's and yeah i was getting a lot on
twitter uh what were people saying like
oh that's me like i mean i'm telling you
there's like 15 to 20 guys are like oh
they're talking about me
like he's doing like a version of me and
i would like scroll through their photos
i'm like i guess i am and you're a
confirmed narcissist
i never i've and it doesn't surprise me
that these people are narcissists
because and at one point um
ayan's talking about how he builds
worlds that millions of people across
the world playing he's right and that's
what a nurse he's right um uh and also
narcissists believe that everything is
is is an extension of them yes yes and
so this is something that we're talking
about constantly which is
is iron a narcissist
uh or is he is he is he narcissist
adjacent that because my concern from
the beginning was like i did this other
show where the the characters never
learn they never grow they never have
the capacity to grow or change because
that would fuck the show up i don't want
to do that again i want to do a show
where maybe we can see that someone that
we could see someone grow and change and
that that it's messy and difficult and
you take two steps forward one step back
but if you try you can melt some of the
shit and the problem with narcissism um
true narcissism is that it's it's it's
like sociopathy to a certain extent lack
of empathy yeah there is no ability to
change that person they're born like
that and they're gonna die like that
unfortunately so uh we wanted to make
sure that maybe
he was exhibiting signs of it but maybe
isn't it wouldn't be uh necessarily like
um
because there are i know
come for me in the comments see in the
comments on this one but there are
versions of asperger's that do people
can conflate with a narcissist because
you're just not reading other people's
faces you're not reading that they're
not like smiling and like your ideas
necessarily um but narcissists fascinate
me because number one narcissists
narcissists can't acknowledge that
they're a narcissist any kind of
self-criticism would shatter them so if
someone says i think i'm a narcissist
that means they're not a narcissist i
remember going to my therapist being
like my narcissist just because i was
just like you know insecure and thinking
and i'm like i'm doing my stand-up but
i'm standing alone i'm like oh she's
like narcissists don't drive to
therapists and i ask if they think
they're perfect you're self-involved
with yes you're probably absorbed
and i think as i think a lot of people
who do what we do are um and i think to
a certain extent you kind of have to be
yeah because you're you're putting
yourself out there and saying what i
have to say is important and you should
all listen to me and then we like wait
for one thing
and then if you do respond at all a
security person
removes you from the show and you i get
to keep your money
and so and and so we wanted to kind of
build a character like that for him
which is like
that that he's close but he's also
asking the questions because we do
we do slowly start to change him he does
allow for
like
the little crack in his armor to start
to splinter and i think that's what
we're taking them in the seconds you
know it's interesting that i was um uh
reading about narcissist once is that
narcissists all of their narcissism is
very specific to what would have pleased
their dads or primary caretakers so that
there's certain people that are
narcissistic in some areas but not
others because that's not what their dad
cared about so if guys it's like i want
you to be good at sports i want to be
good at fighting but a narcissist that
wants to be good at fighting in sports
they're not going to go to a flower shop
be like i made the best flower
arrangement because their dad didn't
care about that yeah they'll be like i
suck at this i gotta go back to the
thing i'm great at because i'm the best
at it and you need me so there's
something interesting about him like not
needing to be the best at something else
because not get not giving a shit about
yeah and be like oh i'm not good at this
and i was like what
yeah
that's kind of fascinating to me well i
i also again because we do this other
show that nobody learns or grows like i
am interested because of all the things
that you were talking about that i do
think that the dane that we are in a
somewhat dangerous place
not because i like i don't i don't
actually believe in cancer culture i
don't think it's happening
however now gibson has 13 movies in
production yeah i i do think that there
are there is there is a tendency um
out of out of self-preservation
uh to
deem things either holy good or holy bad
like
black white good evil served us very
well uh for the thousands of years that
we did not have street lights it's like
this person's bad just run just make the
generalization and just run right and so
i totally understand it and but and yet
i i'll say that there was we've gotten
incredibly um the show's really well
received which is awesome but every once
in a while i can't believe you didn't
know about your emmys
did nobody tell you i don't know
the other show the other show like is
like i'm so programmed to not like
really actually i actually gave a shit
about all that um but
the um
the the
i don't know what was i just i derailed
you i'm sorry about narcissism
about uh
benson generalizations for safety
yes that is we are programmed to make
things black and white okay so then some
of the criticism that um that uh that
i've seen
um
and i don't put any stock into it but it
makes me nervous about the way that
people are sort of approaching
some of the popular culture is
i don't like this show because i don't
know if they're saying iron is good or
bad
and i'm like wow that's really dangerous
that's someone who needs a decision that
can't um tolerate gray yes yes and i can
understand it if you're saying okay the
sopranos right because that's clearly
someone who is
what they're not well david chase was
never suggesting this is a good guy but
they're saying he's a fascinating
character and you're either interested
in it or not they show some good parts
of him and some bad parts of him but
clearly david was saying this is a
dangerous person and and most likely
it's not going to end well for him
whereas i think with our show i don't
think we're presenting that at all i
think we're presenting a person who's
like
messy and difficult and not great but
also not terrible i mean not like not
wholly terrible not entirely terrible
there are there is room for growth there
and if you don't allow for that
it's like we have episodes of sunny
where people are always asking like oh
would you change something and sunny
and of course i would if i had a time
machine i would go back and go like oh i
never thought about it like that and
what we were intending the intent of
what we were going for is not what
actually came across and people are and
i understand that now but i didn't know
that at the time for whatever reason the
blind spot it's it's that's fascinating
to me i had i i was working on this just
to because i just did this with your
show i have to uh out my with the uh
episode about um fast forwarding through
that standalone episode i just made a
meaning that you didn't intend um but uh
one time i had this joke because i'm
doing this big bit about how phones are
so much safer for kids kids are safer
than they've ever been we grew up on
like you know our slides were like sheet
metal they would bake in the sun like we
didn't have we played on seesaws and
played fucking bloody knuckles and shit
which is kind of secretly my theory
about the rings it's like um
uh what are those things brass knuckles
it's like every like guys are kind of
programmed to want brass knuckles and
when i looked at his i was like he
should probably just wear brass knuckles
that's probably what he's like
connecting to about it i if you i can go
down we can go down the ring road for a
second put it all with you okay yeah
guys guys don't like rings unless
they're newer rings one of the ring the
rings the beard like what it's just like
a way to distance yourself even in minor
ways from
the world also the chris angel joke came
at the perfect time it was like the
perfect time to do that joke like anyone
else would have put it in the first
episode it was like perfectly timed um
but i was working this joke about how
kids um oh kids play with their phone
they're really dangerous okay we played
with matches like we played we put paper
bags on our heads like we played let's
go jump off that thing we played hold
your breath and then matches would
sometimes would kill and sometimes it
wouldn't and finally comet came up to me
and was like
when i picture matches i picture them
not lighting
whereas i picture going
you know so it's like you were picturing
a different thing like my setup was
flawed because i couldn't do the mind
share that made everybody's mind go to
the same exact image yes yes and so you
know when i was 27 years old and i would
never even at 27 and probably at 17 or
15 maybe 15 i don't know but i would
never write a joke that was like
punching down right on a marginalized
group however
that's in retrospect you look back and
you go oh that's not what we were
intending but because of the language we
were using that that is what what winds
up happening and so okay you can either
pull the episode and act like it never
never right right right which seems dark
to me it seems really dark which is
again is a lot of history eraser stuff i
mean i'm not going to get involved in
the statue debate but it's like where if
we erase all the stuff from history
books and get rid of all these books in
schools like how are they ever going to
know that this has happened before but
right so i think there's a difference
between pretending something didn't
happen or continuing to celebrate right
so i don't think by having the show
exist
uh on a platform is saying well we're
still celebrating the very specific
blind spot in season three of this show
as long as you can go back and
retroactively look at it and say oh okay
we can ameliorate that thing and the way
that we can is by having one of the
characters recognize that oh
right that was not what my intent was my
intent was this that doesn't mean that
in sunny the characters learned anything
it means that we as a show did and then
how can we get
creative to to right that wrong while
also dancing the line of not changing
the character because that would be
inauthentic and yet still getting our
audience and the general audience to
recognize that we as the filmmakers have
have learned something really important
and it's not just with like quote
unquote woke shit uh it's also like
like you said like we've been really
careful about not assuming that like
people that voted for trump or dumb or
working-class people are dumb um and
what's really interesting about sonny is
that i'll go let's say to a frat house
in south carolina
right and and they'll be like
or i don't hang out a lot of frat houses
but i mean like you know i'll run to a
bunch of frat boys right and they'll say
how do you make that show
in l.a and i'm like what do you mean
they're like you just fucking rip apart
like woke culture and
all the times you're going to drink the
baby blood how do you even have the time
yeah and i'm like wow is that what you
think the show is and they're like
clearly and then i'll talk to my more
liberal friends obviously i'm surrounded
by them here and they'll say oh how like
like you are really like how do you go
to south carolina and walk around and
talk to those kids you're like really
ripping them apart and i'm like really
is that what you think the show is so i
think everybody sees the show in a
different light yeah we're either
ripping apart like neo-liberalism or
neo-conservatism and the truth is we're
we're doing both and neither and it's
like whatever you project on to it will
ian have that in the show where he'll
look back at a game and go like uh
do we delete a diamond okay we're on i
knew him since childhood when he was ian
like and go back and say like oh god
like i'm or someone you know we'll look
at something in retrospect or is there
ever any crossover
ever because it'd be funny if ayan's
favorite show was sunny but it's it
started sucking after season three man
it started after he did that dance with
the
yeah
which i get a lot it started
not having the whatever jokes that you
look back that you think you might
delete oh we we have yeah well we have
people who really think that we jumped
the shark and we jumped the shark 16
times
when i did an episode where i did this
like four minute long contemporary dance
and like straight up people were like
that's when they ruined it i'm like
okay well i know where you said i know
where you stand i know the way that you
are no you can't you can't just sit in
your uh cringe awkwardness yeah i know
you constantly need like a million cuts
a minute to be able to not have be alone
with your own thoughts yes yes so i mean
i i think that we're already starting to
do that with the show and with iron
where he's able to um
let poppy in in a way that he hasn't and
i think that that's that shows some
level of maturity and growth but but i
also don't i want to make sure that it's
um
that it feels authentic to someone's
real experience which is that he's not
all of a sudden gonna go oh
now i get it and then change his
character completely and i think in a
lot of ways i'm sure this will come out
wrong it is also comedians and comedy's
job to sort of to take a risk when it's
like you know this communion's not funny
some huge comedians like okay so you're
saying all the people in there laughing
are dumb
they're then why are they all laughing
if he's not funny you know so to me i
think ian's is same thing with anything
they're not making another black panther
because they feel sorry for the actors
or anyone it's because it made a ton of
money you know so it's it's not what
does it say about the person making it
what does it say about all the people
buying it yeah you know so are we
supposed to give people what they want
are we supposed to give people what they
should want you know and so to me a lot
of the times in this in this moment
where everyone's like you can't say
anything it's i'm gonna say it but then
i'm if it's not funny anymore that means
they're done yeah that means that that
you know so there's something kind of
fascinating like what we laugh at says
so much about who we are as a person
well that's what we're always asking
ourselves is like okay fine break it
down to the point for the right reasons
the wrong way exactly break it down to
the physics what's the joke like
ultimately what are you saying what are
you saying yes what's the what's the
joke and i'm fascinated with bringing up
james gandolfini i'm fascinated by
characters that
if they do the wrong things for the
wrong reasons we hate them but if they
do the wrong things for the right
reasons if you're in the mafia to feed
your kids you know if there's there's
something i think that's the little hook
to get someone like ian ian
so clearly like loves giving people an
escape from their reality it's so
important to him there's something um i
don't know just so charming about that
tonight well for whatever reason like
people love and i've just noticed this
in the stuff that i watch people love
audiences i love as an audience member i
love to watch somebody who's really good
at something yes like that's the number
one that's such a fascinating character
trait that seems so simple but it's
right like whether they're
whether they're good at slaughtering
people or they're good at making a video
game or they're good at it being uh a a
cobbler sassy waitress yeah yeah you're
just like oh wow that i enjoy watching
them be good at that and i will because
i think to me
inherent perfectionists are people that
want to be the best at what they do
you're like okay i'm never going to be
the best at that so i can just enjoy
this is that me i don't understand
what's happening oh um uh i could never
do that so i don't have to worry about
ever being good at it like i really love
watching you know um what is it water
polo cause i'm like i never want to do
this i don't like this but i love
watching like with comedy it's hard to
watch because i'm like i auditioned for
that or i could have done that better
and it just takes the camera well you
also find that like most people who work
in comedy don't watch a lot of comedy
which is a bummer because it can only
make you better right it's just that you
get kind of
burned out i watch old comedy a lot i
definitely watch old shows i still watch
martin
like stuff like that yeah i mean um
question ancestry i'm obsessed with
ancestry benton do you want to come and
ask your questions real quick oh um uh
what would ian's 23andme come back as
viking ancestry
well i think that's actually really
funny i don't know that's a
oh we should
i'm gonna steal that
because i think there's something really
funny about
uh
getting the results back and not he
makes the whole uh office do it yeah
because i want to be able to i want to
be able to forgive you because you might
have ancestral trauma that i don't know
about yeah if you if you're if i think
that you're you know um it's funny to
say to a aparna's character what's uh
michelle michelle like you could have
nazi ancestry that could be why you're
so stoic and i would i wouldn't take
this personally if i just understood
your epigenetic imprinting what you came
from i i i have you i love this idea
because i have maybe we can cut this and
i'll pay you for that because that's
actually that's really incredible like
the idea of we do it we did a version of
that this year where we had everybody
take a test and then it it it told you
what animal you would be and you'd be on
this animal wheel this is the second
season and
um and i
and it's a great it's a great episode
it's a bottle episode that's just all
the characters interacting and it's fun
because
it has reduced you down to an animal and
then that's really fun because i can be
like well you're a baboon or you're a
shark
right and so there's something fantastic
about actually breaking everybody's dna
down only to just just so i can get a
better sense of what you're wired to do
yeah i should make you be doing this
yeah and he would definitely lie about
it right 100 he'd be like i genghis khan
is my dad yes
yeah i actually think that that's a good
and that's a good thing yes
the one that raped six thousand women a
week
oh he conquered a lot of territory there
weren't many humans at the time he's the
reason you know we didn't go extinct um
but that's fascinating to me also uh i
do feel first of all david hornsby yeah
uh just real for i i'm like obsessed
with his ancestry it'd be funny if he
had nazi ancestry and he's like yeah why
am i such a pussy like i've got a nazi
ancestry and he's like let's go
the read of the line when he got fired
when he's like it's hard to get a job as
a white man i know i know actually that
was like like lisa kudrow almost yeah
level what i find with david is like
people like general audiences they find
characters that they love and
charlotte's fucking incredible and
there's so many joe is so funny play as
played by jessie ennis there's so many
great characters
people in comedy that i talk to like if
they watch the show um
david is the one where they because he's
doing so much i don't know how you keep
a straight face i do see a lot of
singles on him though i'm like is this
just i could never be in a two shot
without keeper just kills me yeah he's
so funny um i also just want to say real
quick
uh that you are a hero in my eyes
because you made the only
small wonder joke
i have ever approved of small wonder was
my favorite favorite show growing up i
pers based my entire personality on her
and so i wore this special shirt for you
today i appreciate that i watched i've
probably seen every episode obsessed
yeah obsessed i have the costume to wear
for halloween it's uh it's wild remember
like mr belvedere remember like i mean
all these shows imagine when people make
references to television shows i can
promise you i've seen everything can you
pitch me three's company right now i'm
an executive
well
i think about this quite a bit me too
quite a bit
i think about like what was that what
was the pitch
of three's company
it's about we're we're a writing team
okay well it's about these two beautiful
women i mean one's really beautiful wait
i'm sorry can i interrupt for a second
to ask a question
what decade are we are we pitching it in
2021 or are we pitching it in 1970
because you pitch it in two different
ways because if it's 1979 you're like
two hot chicks you're using that yeah
you don't want to fuck the one but you
want to fuck the other one but the one
is a sour plus because she's funny
because she's this output the one's
really dumb and then we got a guy and
the joke is
that that we're gonna he's pretending
he's not he's a pansy yeah he's a parent
he's one of the queers yes he's one of
them queers and the and the fudge
and the uh and the the um and then
there's a guy the manager doesn't yeah
or larry well larry and he's just funny
because all these guys are yeah larry
slater comes in says yes slave no with
the ladies yeah he's the genghis khan of
wherever that took place that's right
and we're going to have him constantly
trying to fuck these women but they
don't want to fuck him but but he's
going to go out there and he's going to
or at least he thinks he's slaying out
there and then the landlord is older
which means he's like a manic mess
because old people are just dumb and
crazy all the time yeah so everyone will
relate to that yeah and uh but we're
gonna give him sort of like an
effeminate flare too for no appearance
he's wearing a house dress yeah sort of
progressive looking back even though
yeah even though the whole joke was that
he thought
yeah it was a little confusing because
mr furley would wear
like collared um like phyllis diller
scars scarves and whatnot i wonder if
i'm always fascinated by how something
like that comes about like you know
there's a story about leonardo dicaprio
where in um uh revenant he showed
because it was an 11 month shoot and
they were only using all natural light
that whole thing and he chose fingerless
gloves and then like a month into the
shoot he was like i need i i'm freezing
like well that's it but when actors make
a choice or you do something to fix
something else and then the story behind
why it was like that if he had like
gotten surgery on his neck and they had
to do that and then i just loved that
like trivia stuff yeah well i i think
that's a sale in 79. i don't think
that's a sale in uh even 22. even pretty
woman 21. i mean she was supposed to die
at the end like i just i love that shit
i love those little tidbits
pitch
give it the let's go we don't you don't
have to pitch it but i i'm all often
times
picturing the
the pitch room of golden girls
because it's wild like there's no way
that you're any women first of all there
were no um women on that staff i guess
well susan harris
oh yeah that's right oh that's right she
created it but i don't know that she
knows some writers that wrote on it
because paul junger whit i think was
like the
the the executive producer but like gary
david goldberg was on that before yeah i
was
well it's interesting because i do think
there's something
this is gonna get me in trouble but
there's something cool about when men
write women and women write men because
we actually
you know we when we say only men can
write women men and only women who have
women it's like that's so ignorant and
assuming
that um
that masculinity and femininity can't
exist in others so to me i love when
guys write for me because they're not
like how's my hair because you know what
i'm saying it's like there's something
they write me like a man do you know
what i have a very awesome person
another person that you were with who i
met at the party at the caa party 12
years ago
you were with him
he's michael patrick
yes yes yes yes very famously i mean
knows i mean like i'm like can you just
write this for me write my vows right
like right everything yeah i i did sort
of feel a little bit like um
everyone's gonna project their own thing
onto this but i got you know ian and
poppy i'm like that's kind of me and
michael
you know kind of cool um but we were
gonna talk about sunny
uh and first i wanna ask you are these
the gifts you gave him yes they are for
his wife not him oh they're for his
wife's uh uh emotional spiral into
rescuing cats which is an addiction you
can't stop
okay i just want to double check why do
you have notes for my gifts so many
you know what he does not have a tinfoil
hat for cats
no but we do have animal puzzles but i
like this one that one's like super cool
i got a place called boo radley's in
spokane washington it's like the coolest
that's cool yeah um the coolest toy
store on the planet and they just it's
like spencer's gifts but like
sick but like to kill a mockingbird
stuff yes exactly
yeah the whole thing everything's
um yeah i just i'm a hoarder also
i i notice and if i don't give you those
i'm going to get a cat just to put the
hat on something okay so this is going
to stop me from becoming a cat lady okay
i love that bended said something really
profound about your character on sunny
and i feel like you should say it not me
yeah i was just your character on sunday
is so interesting because
one it portrays
a gay male it's really one of the only
in my opinion examples of like a
masculine gay male on television
and also a that's has not really very if
any stereotypes attached to it and was
that like a choice that you made or did
that happen because you
had a character first that just happened
to be gay later
that's probably the honest answer yeah
is that like i
he very clearly in the very beginning
he was a straight man or at least what
we we retroactively justified that he
was in the closet and like and hiding
this for various reasons but but yes i
originally started playing him just as a
straight man and then when we but we
made a conservative concerted effort to
make sure that once we did
transition into
not only suggesting but then having him
come out
and admit to being gay that we didn't
change him we didn't change his
character and people could still make
fun of definitely and that's not that's
not treating you as an equal that's
saying you're too fragile for me to joke
with that's right and so we do make it
very clear that the characters are like
we hate you like we dislike you but not
and we don't want to spend any time with
you but not because you're gay we don't
give a fuck about whether you're getting
it it's you we don't like and and that's
what we i what i found is just really
awesome like about the community too and
and the embrace that i've i've felt over
the years that and and
that i get more often than not which is
thank you for not changing the character
into
maybe what could be perceived as or
actually be just virtue signal bullshit
yeah so we really try to actively fight
against that and make sure that the
character itself
he's exactly like them just like dee
right so like he's a woman but we didn't
like change her we didn't want her to be
like when she's getting her nails done
she was just she was just a one of you
guys that's right so it's like we want
the characters are not real human beings
they're they're id
right like
manifested id so like
d is a female version of this manifested
id and so mac is a gay version of that
and why why can't
the a gay man also be as abhorrent as
the rest of these characters yeah why
can't they it's the real question it's
like well it's like what david yellow
said when he was on the podcast he was
like if you're a black filmmaker it has
to win an oscar we're not we're not
equal until we can make mediocre movies
like everybody else well it just seems
like you wrote a gay character that's
not for straight people also like it's
not a lot of gay characters are written
i think to be digestible for straight
people to make you feel bad for gay
people to make you empathize for gay
with gay people and they're wrote
they're written for them whereas this
character show their trauma yeah it's
like it's all about yeah it's about like
how can i make you feel bad for this
person so that it betters their life in
the real world which isn't necessarily
accurate whereas this character is like
still
that really flawed yeah yeah and really
messed up and is that was i mean that
was a choice oh yeah yeah no that was
definitely a choice like we wanted to
make again we wanted to make sure that
it felt authentic to the show so that i
don't know if this is because i grew up
in the community or and i'm sure it
absolutely has a lot to do with that but
um i was it was just always normalized
to me because everybody i knew was was
gay or at least at 50 of the people i
knew were gay so it wasn't and even
though i went to catholic school it
seemed like my friends didn't care and
they were all aware of it it just didn't
seem like it was that big of a of a deal
and then i moved from philly to new york
and then all of my friends in new york
so
yes i i could recognize that um
that obviously um
the lgbtq community was marginalized
objective standpoint but it didn't i
wasn't always like feeling it
nevertheless i wanted to make sure that
once we went down this direction with
the show
that um that we were i hate using this
word because it's it's it's terrible out
of context but it's true that we wanted
to normalize right so that the only way
to normalize it in the context of sunny
was to make sure that the character was
exactly the way he was prior to
to coming out but i would say you know
look
if you have the the
i've heard a lot of criticism about will
and great the original will and grace
you know recently which i think is
fascinating because people are looking
at it from the lens like specifically
shawn's character looking at it through
the lens of 2021 right
where maybe he was like that character
was reinforcing stereotypes or whatever
it might be but that's
fucking bullshit because that show to me
i don't know how you guys feel about
that show but like to me single-handedly
did
um
for the community what i what i could
only dream of doing like
in in the mid to late 90s we're
basically saying like these are people
just like you welcome welcome them into
your neighbor into your living room
every once a week and you can see that
the the thing the things that they're
going through the same things that
you're going through and so again using
that word like normalizing the community
um i think was like super profound so
any like little thing that i can do to
continue that is true but i think that
hollywood took that that really good
thing and now they've made that's not
now the blueprint you now are gay and
you're a sidekick to a sassy woman you
don't have a love interest you end up
alone you're killed off you're like
there's they take that as long as you
can be
that you can better the life of a
straight person you're a great character
yeah but it's really interesting to have
a show
where you portray
um
a character that's flawed and that's
masculine and that is
synonyms yeah just lots of synonyms
but um i lost my train of thought on
that when you spoke but i had a point
that's kind of my thing it's a power
move can i as you're saying that i want
to yeah go ahead because i don't
remember whatever
we were saying that as long as it uh uh
betters the life of a straight character
it's also always has to steal the scene
has to come in say the funniest thing
and then you can't have anything to live
for but like being helping improving
your life like i mean if you fashion
advice like something's wrong with you
they make you a spicy drink yeah yeah
like it's always something like that
where's like it's very rare to see a
character that's like one like kind of
like a like a leader in the lead
ensemble that's not
struggling all of their jokes are based
on being gay they have nothing else
going on with their life they don't have
any allergies they don't you know have a
house being renovated it's just like
everything goes back to gay gay gay or
sex or being obsessed with man which i
notice your character doesn't have a
love attraction nobody's saying i really
have a love interest really no one will
love them
that's a conscious choice
please have been rolling on that take
two just so you guys know how authentic
we are
we i haven't given a whole lot i haven't
lectured you guys in a while about how
authentic we are about our sponsors and
who we work with we don't work with
anybody where we don't actually use
their product so much so that emily went
to go take out the outstanding foods uh
meal in a bag puffs and guess what they
were open
because i was really eating them i'm not
gonna eat them now because you guys get
mad when i do my nom noms on the
microphone
and i'm trying to hold these very
delicately so everyone out there with
misophonia doesn't have a panic attack
and and get in a car accident on the on
the interstate
do you call it the interstate or the
freeway i called the highway i caught
the highway too that's something that
we're from the same place that's right
that'll do it so
anyway
back to us being authentic and real real
emily wants to play a game
emotional games aside we do that at
night what do you want to do on the show
what kind of game you want to play now
this is a fun game called i like to call
ride or die okay
i'm going to read off some rumored celeb
rider requests and you're going to tell
me who you think it is multiple choice
okay like a writer like how
it's a writer's a list of things that
celebrities request to have backstage
for them when they do things right when
you're like jennifer lopez right right
right white orchid right right right the
game is such a clever title rider die
get it like yeah no i saw you laughing
at your computer earlier when you were
writing this if it's not in there
they'll kill you yeah ride or die oh
yeah okay okay okay all right here we go
the first one okay not all this worked
for the bosses you had
you were one of them
that would have just been by accident
okay
yogurt pretzels licorice sour candy and
advil liquid gels
is this kylie jenner andy dick or meghan
markle meghan markle has a writer
uh
advil
liquid gels that sounds like andy deck
he's always like
falling all over the place getting
punched in the face
kylie jenner oh really which to me seems
so reasonable
advil yeah yeah it does you know i
thought it was going to be like
little people
[Laughter]
the person who doesn't let me say eskimo
on the show
i didn't say dwarf
or
that's the right thing
[Laughter]
see if they can catch them in their
mouths
to juggle them
[Laughter]
all right
next one
one grande iced caramel latte with two
sweetened lows one grande iced americana
with two sweetened lows and soy milk and
one slice of pumpkin loaf is this
beyonce taylor swift
or the mermaid from starbucks
you guys emily
has been laughing at this joke that she
wrote
for the last two and a half hours and
she cannot even get through it look for
me from the cup
[Applause]
it's there's nothing funny about this
it's so funny to her that we're just
we're not sure what to do except just
let her have it so
guess the mermaid from starbucks it's
taylor swift taylor swift and needs
banana pumpkin uh in her writer yeah
that makes me love her even more i know
i love oh god taylor if you ever watch
this i love you taylor you know you do
need outstanding foods okay
last one
tell me which celeb this is
who's ryder reads
take your time emily this ad's only been
seven and a half minutes
one bag of pig out piglets pork rinds in
texas barbecue flavor
one bag of pig out piglets poor grinds
and nacho cheese flavor that is not your
best
[Laughter]
one this is nacho podcast
yeah
one bag of pig out piglets pork rinds
and hella hot flavor one bag of pig out
piglets pork rinds and salt and vinegar
flavor one bag of pig out pork rind one
bag of pig out piglets pork rinds in
original flavor
and grace
that is my rider and i am not ashamed of
it this is always what i eat on the road
all of their products are gmo
free gluten-free free of artificial
ingredients trans fats cholesterol and
soy and our certified kosher certified
plant-based and certified gluten free if
that's not joe's style
i don't mess with you
we've worked out an exclusive deal for
good for you listeners receive 25 off
your first order go to
outstandingfoods.com
whitney or use code whitney at checkout
to claim this deal do you know that also
has iron and vitamin d and minerals this
is literally what vitamin d is what
you're supposed to be taking during the
pandemic just saying that's o u t s t a
n d i n g f o o d s dot com slash which
needs pure good for you we're showers
and not tellers so we would like to show
you some video footage of what i used to
be like on tour before i started
drinking course pure
[Music]
i'm just sitting there
miserable
bored
distraught
no fun at all
look at me dorky sweatpants
oh
a pair of sunglasses on my head that
doesn't even block the sun
just got those to try to look cool
because i can't act cool so i try to
cheat it with cool sunglasses that's how
lame i am pre-course pure and now here's
a video of whitney now that i've
discovered coors pure this is me now
this is whitney now turn down for what
look at that
are you giving out money i'm just no
it's invisible money it's invisible
money wait you didn't see my dance at
the end yeah wow
makes you an incredible dancer that i
think we can agree on that is scientific
those moves i do feel like coors pure
i'm not a wine person it's too heavy for
me i get headaches next day this is the
perfect buzz because it's not too much
you know it's like i feel like i was
dancing
but with the girls right that's the buzz
that i want making friends in the
bathroom making friends in the bathroom
you know like it's not the kind of buzz
where you get drunk and you're like
she's prettier than me who do you think
you are like right i was like i was the
best version of myself with no dark
thoughts right right i believe
coors pure
when i drink it it brings out the best
in me i love that not the worst in me i
love that you've never seen me on it
i would love to please drink that whole
can
it is a refreshingly simple beer with
organic barley organic hops and water
that's it no garbage no trash 92
calories and zero sugar coarse pure is
the perfect beer to celebrate every day
winds of life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt reach for coors pure it's
organic but chill about it
go to course you feel so light go to
coursepeer.comwhitney to see where you
can find coors pure celebrate
responsibly coors brewing company of
albany georgia and the can's not
embarrassing
saying it's like chic it's cute it
matches all my horse shirts
the mountain that's what we look for in
a beverage
we're doing an episode right now that
we're writing um and that that basically
all the characters become but very
specifically mac becomes obsessed with
his identity and how he identifies and
to your point that's something we talk
about all all the time which is like
the the joke shouldn't be
that
his character shouldn't just be based on
the fact that he's gay right and that's
what you traditionally see and that was
your point which is like oh well that's
the joke the joke is he's gay so no the
joke is that for mac specifically is
that whether or not he jumps head first
into that is kind of an indictment and
then a satire on basically that framing
so for example the way that mac looks at
himself they were like okay mac it kind
of the 23andme thing kind of like
was a version of what we're talking
about which is like i'm gonna try and
define who i am so max like okay i
define myself by by three guiding
principles like number one i identify as
badass like that's number one number two
i identify as irish catholic
all right so badass number one irish
catholic number two and then gay's
number three
and so and anything that gets like
in in between you know the number one
like is gonna be a problem and i think
mac would rather be badass than he than
gay and that's why this show is so
fucking weird and fucked up and strange
so he's always going to be gay i just
happen to be gay that is not that that's
right i just happen to be this but in
the same way that i just happened to be
a badass and but the point is that
everybody
like rolls their eyes and they're like
what the fuck are you talking about i
have lyme disease why are we talking
about that yes i mean i just in the way
that i think will and grace was really
influential for their time i kind of
feel like sunny is that way now because
i'm one of the people who i believe
allies are
probably the most important part of any
movement because then get the people
that you can't get to that people will
listen to them for whatever reason like
because you can relate and i think
that's kind of what your character is
doing that and this generation in a lot
of ways and you have a lot of guys i
know but yeah yeah that's my but my
question is do you like that effects
thing i know my friend zach he's like
you're like his hero and like he will
literally say things like he wants to
write all this stuff and he'll say
things like well rob wouldn't say that
or rob wouldn't do that or like and the
impact of just seeing that character
evolve hasn't i think affected a lot of
like bro it's about people that are
massive guys that are like you're that
were beaten up saying you cannot be gay
i know a lot of them went to that are
now
you know masculine just the idea of like
i gotta push it down i just gotta punch
as many guys as i can a week to not deal
with what's going on with me it's like
you know people think that all you know
gay people have come out of the closet
by 18 there's a whole generation of men
that have had to sort of overcompensate
with like hyper masculinity in order to
not deal with that because there wasn't
you know a ways to see yourself on
instagram and igtv and tick tock and
stuff like that that wasn't available to
them you know so i also love that it's
happening at a late stage in his life
because most people don't get to come
out at 12 and just be unconditionally
supported by their parents the way we
see them yeah and and we also chose to i
think like i think the character came
the joke is that the charac look all of
the characters are completely um
have no sense of of themselves and
they're completely not self-aware in any
way and so um at one point
uh i think the character came out and
there was like i noticed on social media
there was like like literally came out
to his friends and there was this big
social media um
push to me um that everybody was like
really excited and then i was like oh
shit because i know that we have this
other episode where he goes back in the
closet and we thought well that's
it to us it was interesting for the show
to watch this guy struggle with this
where he just goes out and comes back in
and goes out and comes back in and
meanwhile all of his friends are like we
we we don't care like you don't you just
stop telling us this just do whatever
you want we don't care and then when we
put them back into the closet the
outpouring was really devastating to me
because people were really sad and upset
and i never thought about it that way i
never thought about sunny as maybe being
um
being a show that the community would
embrace the way that they actually did
which is why we in the season after
um where i just put basically put it to
bed was like i want to do something that
sonny never does uh and we changed the
tone of an entire sequence of the show
that was probably um i mean
one of the most important uh
sequences in the show as far as i'm
concerned in the 14 years and it was the
thing that probably brought me the most
joy um and that was this this coming out
to my father sequence that we did and
then from that point forward um
what i've been hearing the most it isn't
necessarily just from the community
which obviously feels good uh but it's
i'll be around town or i'll be i'll be
on social media and the first thing i'll
hear is um
bro
i'm not gay but
right people love to start sentences
they love it okay and and normally
they'll say i don't usually think women
are funny yeah but right i'm not gay but
i think you're really funny great okay
so here's
so here's the thing i see that now i can
absolutely recognize that a person who's
been marginalized their whole life could
hear that and just be like what the fuck
however i i'm i would suggest that this
represents great growth from somebody
from large sections of the population
who
needed that like need to use that
verbiage to
yes they're hedging to a certain extent
but then they are saying i'm not gay but
you
did this episode and it meant something
to me like i cried at the end of this
episode i felt something that i haven't
felt before and i'm like oh wow and then
you follow up on the conversations and
they're not maybe ready to continue down
that road but it feels as though you
cracked a little bit of that armor right
you are having an impact on a group of
people that is very hard to get to yeah
like in the way that will and grace did
you know and i think that's why earlier
you mentioned how you have a larger
female fan base now i think that's why i
think you kind of represent like like to
women and to people that are othered
what like straight white men can be what
they should but how they cannot really
be if they have tools and that they
aren't like so hung up on being like
toxic and masculine and being all these
things that we all these words we throw
around i think that's probably why
there's such a huge shift well i i hope
so i mean i it's certainly the
characters themselves are not um are not
vessels for that but i think the
audience going back to what you were
saying earlier which is like giving the
audience the benefit of that that
they're smarter than you think
that people are watching the show and
they recognize that well the characters
are one thing but the filmmakers are
something else and that they're going
along that ride with us
and if if i'm that or a version of that
and i can kind of infuse the show with
that then people
get it right it's not the show shouldn't
be taken on face value and if i'm that
it's only because of the way i was
raised so i have the benefit
again
it's not that i don't have judgment on
people who feel the way that they feel
let's just say they're homophobic for
example
okay
of course do i want them to be
homophobic no
i
me i i had the luxury and the pleasure
of being raised in the community so it
was always something to me
that i
had access to and had information on and
had relationships with and so it was
easy for me to
like you hit a certain point where
you're like
oh i didn't realize that anybody
actually felt any way other than this
because i've always been in the
community yeah yeah um so i try
again not to be true i thought it was
fine until i came to hollywood and
realized everyone was racist and sexy
yeah and they took coming here there was
truly a point in my life where uh this
actually happened i grew up in philly
which is a majority black city in the
gay community i went to temple uh for
summer school between okay right so my
high school was right next to temple um
in north philly and then and then you
went to school in west philly so you i
mean the it's it's majority black so i
remember being in like fourth grade
and learning about the word minority
like what the word minority meant and it
was okay and i remember asking the
teacher what does it mean and she said
well it means like a population that's
in this context that's
less than or fewer than in numbers and
so for an example you are a
you will be a white man and therefore a
you are in a minority and i was like no
i'm not that doesn't make any sense
she's like no you're not understanding
you are a straight white man and not and
the vast majority of people are not
straight
uh are straight white men
and i was like that's not true that's
not what that word means and she's like
i don't think you understand what the
word might and i said no i as a straight
white man am a minority
and she was like you don't understand
what the word is and i was like i don't
think you understand what the word is
because
it felt to me and of course it wasn't
true but it felt to me like i was in the
minority i didn't feel oppressed in any
way yeah but i felt like it's just math
what do you mean you look around and
you're like oh this is just what the
world is it's like theo has that great
bit about that yeah you grow up like
imagine growing up in the west village
of new york yeah you just look around
you're two years old and you're like oh
well this is what life is or anywhere in
new york city which is why it's so great
to when people sort of want to roll
their eyes and why um disney movies that
are diverse is so important because
that's when kids are really going oh
this is what the world looks like yes
and then they go see a bunch of white
people and they're like this is not what
the world should look like it looked
diverse you know that's why you know i
think people it's so important to have
that in movies so that the world looks
the way it ideally i mean i just think a
character like that is breaking even
going back to like the i'm not gay but
statement i think that statement comes
out of fear like i'm scared that if i
like a female comic if i like a gay
movie that it makes me in some way gay
yep
even even going back to like your
statement earlier when you were talking
about like men can't wear rings well
that's imp men implied that they're the
ones that said you can't wear rings no
one else is that well because benjamin
needs to work with something there's
this whole thing where like men almost
make their own fears like i'm scared
that i'll be called the thing that i'm
going to call you
the thing so you're running from your
own you're chasing your own tail you're
running from your own shadow everyone's
fine with no no one's no one's thinking
about you at all and then so just having
a character like that and then listening
to interviews like this with a person
like you i think it that is like
[Music]
more impactful than like
glad being like and we put a tap dancing
gay in the show yeah like that's okay
cool but you got the term right in the
show it's like okay you know but um but
did you were you on that call with
michelle obama when she did a call to
talk to showrunners no she didn't i
wasn't invited through that she didn't
know here's the thing i still have yet
to find anyone who was on it apparently
uh there was there was a call i was on
it where it was um maybe you were fined
maybe it was just you
i thought it was just you and her
dressed up i wore a blazer a green
blazer and it was like an audio call and
i was like what am i doing but i sat and
um she got on the call with a bunch of
show runners still don't know who was on
the call probably just the ones that
were like test tusk ink and she said it
was her last year in office and she
wanted to make a big the biggest impact
she could in every way and she said we
can now connect the success of the show
will and grace to the passage of
marriage equality they looked at all the
cities that had the highest numbers of
watching it and then they looked at how
they voted and so she said can you
please start putting different kind of
characters in your show
because we're finding this is what
changes people having them in their your
home in your living room for you know
years at a time and you're investing and
caring because you go oh well if jack
wants to get married of course you
should be able to get married and then
they're not thinking gay people are
thinking my friend jack yeah i tell you
all the time most people in mill america
like in towns i grew up in little town
like that what you see on tv is the
world that's how you learn how to help a
taxi that's why i learned how to get on
a plane like what you see on tv is the
truth until you find out that it's not
fascinating like so what you're telling
people on television whether it's with
roseanne or something else that's real
to them yeah that's you're representing
what they think i think you don't have
sex from watching because you don't do
whatever you saw in movies yeah because
you don't have the resources or anything
to leave towns like that all the time so
all you have is that like that's why and
like they're just a theory but like
that's why they can sing competitions
things like that you notice that country
artists tend to win a lot of singing
competitions because people that work in
areas that listen and live that way they
go home after work and watch television
they vote they have time to do those
things people live in big cities they're
hustling they're out they're moving
they're about they're they're seeing a
lot more they're not they have time to
be become good singers you mean no i'm
saying like
fans they have more fans because those
people that like music like that the
like people like that like a
hard-working southern person on
television they go home and they watch
sitcoms they watch singing competitions
they watch the view they watch those
shows yep because there's what else are
you gonna do right
fascinating and so i mean what you put
out there is really important in that
way yeah it was just great to hear them
say that i'm letting you go i'm just
asking one more thing okay
what have you said no to because you've
had a million opportunities to be in big
movies stuff like have you ever said no
to anything you're like i wish i'd done
it i don't have i don't have big
opportunities to be in big movie i don't
have i don't have a lot of incoming
calls that's so interesting do you think
it's because you're all because this
happens to me sometimes where people
come up to me and they'll be like i'd
love to have you in this movie but like
i know you only do something if you make
it i'm like no i don't i tend to only
make it because you guys keep telling me
i'm too tall or too funny or not funny
enough or not pretty enough or too
pretty like i just had to start writing
things for myself i'd love to do someone
else's thing yeah i i have heard that
before which is like oh we thought you'd
just do your own thing do you want to be
in this and come on would i not want
a lot of the calls i'll get will be
hey we have this script it's shit um but
we uh own it and we'll own it outright
but we'll pay you a nominal fee to come
in and fix it for us i'm like what the
fuck are you talking about yes i'll pass
on that
but very rarely do i get um oh like
would you like to come in and act on
this yes actually everyone's gonna
like friends will ask me to do cameos or
something like that but but it's
interesting because he has castle and i
mean fargo you were unbelievable thanks
fucking um unbelievable and uh no it's
to me people come up to me and they're
like i'd love you to be in um my move
but like make it your own like do
whatever you want i'm like no no i want
to do what you wrote yeah like i don't
this isn't my show like i would love to
come be a guest and say your writing you
know and then they'll be like was that
okay do you want to see it i'm like i i
don't yeah this is your thing i would
love nothing more than to come in at six
and leave at seven instead of coming at
2 a.m and leave at midnight
like i would love that but it's i'm just
i was just curious about that because
well because you
you've proven yourself as a as a creator
and as a boss and as an executive
producer and so and also a performer but
so you're looked at as those things
first i think and then i was acting like
a showrunner yes i was acting like a
wrestler
dirty secret yeah dude i mean that's
what we all do yeah yes and that's
that's the biggest advice whenever
anybody is asking me like well why do
you have
why why do you why how can you like how
did you learn how to do this i'm like
you don't you just guess and then you
hopefully have some kind of mentorship
or you have some kind of like support
system but you're just faking it all the
way through and
this is what i'm trying to impress upon
as many young people that ask about like
our positions and how do you get to the
position i'm like you got to kind of
push your way through it and then you
have to have the confidence in yourself
to suggest that you can actually do the
thing and then and just recognize that
everybody nobody knows what they're
doing like literally nobody knows
and i also recognize that i have the um
the luxury of being of navigating the
world up to this point in my late 20s
where it truly was open for me even
though i didn't feel like it was because
we grew up poor in philly
even poor in philly if you're a stray
white dude like the world opens itself
to you in ways that that other people
it's not open to and i didn't know that
like i truly didn't know that and i
think that's that is the resistance to
um
to uh white privilege that you hear
quite a bit which is like fuck you i
worked for everything i have no one
suggested that you didn't that's right
no one's suggesting that your world that
your life wasn't harder it wasn't hard
as shit it just wasn't as hard as other
people based on these criteria there's
no reason you should really know that
how would you exactly so i didn't
recognize that or know that so i had
this
i probably have a certain amount of
confidence
that was sort of bestowed upon me by the
culture
uh that a lot of people don't that a lot
of people don't have and so either way
it's something i wasn't born with
something you cultivate over time and
i'm trying to like mentor some of the
younger people on mythequest and sunny
to like take ownership of that and then
go do their own shows and i'm sorry i
think you're doing that even people that
don't work for you i know like so many
of my comic friends like you're like
their hero i mean like i have a friend
he like just all he does is write like
spec scripts for sonny he did one about
about the zoo and it like did really
well on reddit or something
and then you guys did
you would have thought that you came to
his house and gave him like a check he
was so thrilled about it and i was like
i just think that like people are paying
attention to like
what people are doing legal nightmare to
be clear rob never read it i never
realized no accepting submissions it's
illegal if you sent it it goes straight
to the lawyer
no it's just don't read it
but what's publicly available there is
this thing that i do where if i have to
do like a big big girl thing where i
have to have a call with people or like
ask for more money or like set a
boundary i really just go how would i
write the scene if my hero was in the
scene like what would that person do
that's awesome advice that is awesome
advice and that is exactly like uh
someone told me that someone gave me
that advice and i was like that is real
that is such a great way to look at it
because we're all playing a part and
you're just like because sometimes we're
confident sometimes we're not sometimes
we feel good sometimes because guess
what the person the actor in the movie
didn't really do that in real life they
just read off a thing and then committed
to it and that's what i do when i have
to have like big girl calls yeah you
know and it really works it's like such
a good little kind of like life hack um
last thing i was just gonna say oh i'm
circling back to the making a movie of
uh mythic uh mythic quest ravens banquet
on a season
uh and they do auditions for to play you
and
it is exactly what hollywood is like
it's like
they just want to call on people that
they're fans of or they think are hot or
they think you know
and then
you would ultimately get played by
justin long but you're like oh jason
mama yeah
yeah
get gospel yeah
joe manganiello
yeah yeah it would be that we actually
had manganello on it
we had manganella on an episode uh he's
the fucking best he's so funny i was in
acting class with him at leslie khan
which is where we used it's always sunny
in philadelphia the pilot to practice
auditions with uh my acting coach who
was a one richie keane
what yep
is he like okay this is the thing like i
i
i i
i very rarely find myself in situations
where
i'm being like hearing this from you is
like really profound to me
and i'll think about it a lot i'll think
about it tonight i'll go home and i'll
tell katelyn about it and i and it will
fuel me uh to keep doing what i'm doing
um
truly because i know what that i know i
have relationships
not directly with people but with shows
or performers or writers or people who i
looked up to or people who i wanted to
be when i was younger and like i know
how
i know what that relationship can be
like so to hear that your friends feel
that way about me is like super profound
and like
it that is the kind of shit that like
will
definitely make me cry at some point but
i'm not gonna do it right now uh but uh
because you haven't hydrated in the four
hours i've helped you because i knocked
all my you're gonna start drawing the
prison
i'm just i want you to have to feel how
poppy feels in the office with me and
drawing the prison box yeah um but but
yeah but but
but on top of that like
i don't get to hear
i just i don't read message boards i
don't read reviews i don't read like i i
so i don't really hear people talking
about my work that often and like so
it's crazy to hear that you were in an
acting class like doing you're doing yes
pretended to have cancer
and she came in
and we did it all i mean the whole
because uh we would work a month on
something uh just to you know whether it
was like a drama a comedy and that's
what we worked on for a month
well that was the article the hammer was
also in the class
as well wow not a scar on my body
what happened to your thumb this was oh
that this is just for me i'm you know
that's that one i said i sent him a
picture of this just to make it
yeah no we were in class together not
one nibble i'm a little insulted frankly
that was the scene that caitlin
auditioned
with to get the job
and you know and then i remember because
we were always i don't think i even had
an agent at the time maybe like a
commercial agent at abrams or something
you know but um i remember all of my
choices and they were very like reverse
reverse reverse verse first and then she
just did it and i was like that's it i
mean i see obviously uh but i was like
oh perfect fucking it's very rare that i
work on something i want something i
mean i was a kid that i wasn't even i
don't think i was even sad eligible but
where i'm not like i feel like i could
have done that better and when you see
caitlyn you're like nope you couldn't
have done it better straight up
even on the mick like shit like she she
i love people that make me angry and
jealous when i see their performances
uh because that's just
when i see caitlyn work i'm like like
how the fuck and again it's just it's
frustrating but she uh like
she doesn't hear that or see that and so
whenever
like people
like the young actors on on mythicquest
like when they came to
our house for the first time and met her
i was like what's going on and they were
like we revere her like we grew up
watching her and yeah and they're like
you're fine whatever we revere her and
and i'm like tell go tell her that
because i'm telling you she doesn't feel
that she doesn't she doesn't get offers
for things like she's she's just going
to work every day and doing her doing
her job i have a theory people tend to
talk shit to our faces and talk nice
behind our backs
you know yeah with that shirt asshole i
mean
i'll tell you right now i think people
like youtube should run everything just
even here in the way you talked about
the different generations and like the
way that you coach people and whitney's
very similar like i think
just the impact that i've seen people
that don't even work in the industry the
way that they say like rob wouldn't say
that or like i should ask this girl
comedian about my character that i'm
writing just because of the impact that
they see on shows like that i mean i
think people like you guys should run
all the shows i want to get it right and
and honestly at the end of the day
there's a selfishness to it you know i
think for the most part progress happens
when there's a little bit of selfishness
at the end like with hollywood it's like
you're never gonna get the people to not
be sexist that right like you're just
gonna have to make something that's not
and then prove that it's lucrative and
go see no one wants to see that other
shit you were doing those days are over
like it's no longer a good business
model you know so it's like
like for me it's like if i get this
character wrong i'm just a bad business
person i'm just like a bad writer you
know i want to get it right but people
don't know and it's also progressive
great people that are looking up to
people like you like like like the two
of you are people that aren't putting
out like hacky material or like
stereotypical characters because they're
seeing that like
they're seeing someone succeed that's
not doing it it's also not funny that's
the other thing it's like when people
walk you know i say tranny it's like go
for it because there's
guys
there wasn't a joke that was a sloppy
like nothing you can say that word in a
clever incisive way if you can figure
out a way to subvert it or like
sublimate it into something where it
makes the people think or whatever yeah
you know great but it's just not a good
joke first
like as but there's so many people that
are being rewarded for that then it's a
racist joke but there's so many people
that are being rewarded for jokes like
that it's very easy to want to lean into
it yeah but to see people that are
succeeding without doing that it kind of
gives you a room to be like i don't do
that either i i i would go one step
further too which is like to your point
incentivizing people
to
and look what the right thing is i i
don't know but in terms of like
in terms of like uh
diversifying the experience right so
that's a word that it's like
just hearing the word diversity freaks
people out because they're like that's a
hot but well to them they just go i'm
not getting a job i'm excluded right
we're making it fair and i don't deserve
to be here so i'm going to lose my job
yeah it's just that probably if you
don't have a job by the way there's so
much fucking work right now and there's
so many different avenues and so many
different opportunities for people to
create shows that if you're not working
there's a number of different reasons as
to why that could be it might not be
your time you haven't gotten lucky yet
you got to keep at it or you're just not
that good right right and there's a
reality to that thank you um and and
maybe historically
like mediocre dudes like were able to
work and now
it kind of just became a meritocracy and
like that's probably gonna be
frustrating for a lot of people but the
whole point is that surrender the
opportunity you know that's the what's
gonna have to happen and uh but it's
interesting to me when everyone's like
oh my god you cast so diver are you your
crew is diverse and all this stuff is
like well that makes the show better
that's what it makes so if you can
incentivize people
in positions of power i didn't feel so
i'm not hiring people off the street i
feel bad for it makes the show it's
selfish on my part that's right and they
say in all um and again bottom line
one-on-one you like use your greed to
make a progressive choice is that
offices that are integrated diverse and
have a lot of women make more money than
ones that don't they just make more
money like so just go okay this is like
actually just me being a good business
person you know even if you're racist
and sexist and that'll never change
about you just like
well i think people are so shocked by
seeing diverse staffs because it's so
hard to get in the room it's so hard to
get the job i talked about this and this
is i was going to talk to you about
clubhouse which is this app where you
can just jump on it anytime and then all
your you know fans will jump they follow
you and they can talk to you at any time
it's just like only fans
and the last thing i will say is that i
went on there and i was um there's a lot
of uh people in the african-american
community that want to be in you know
specific businesses and i asked them i
was like you know because i've really
struggled with in television shows you
hire a hair person and they just can't
do black hair and i'll cast someone and
they're like this person can't do my
hair and you're like wait what their
hair person like what are you talking
about like how can you even get the
union you can't also do black hair or
black makeup whatever and then um i
always thought that was just so
ridiculous and then i go in clubhouse
and there's all these uh
african-american hair and makeup people
and i'm like why don't i know you why
why isn't your resume on my and they're
like because you have to get a union in
order to get a new union you have to
have uh 24 episodes of or 60 days on a
production and that's based on the model
of 24 episodes a year now we're doing
ten six a year and they can't get their
hours they can't even get into the union
so there's a lot of structure uh that
really just keeps people out on the
institutional level that need to yes and
you don't know that again when you're
coming into it and it feels like you're
speaking on behalf of a straight white
man you you don't know that so all
you're seeing is your own struggle your
own struggle your own struggle and then
then i just again have the luxury of
then becoming successful getting what i
want to become and then you start to and
then i'm open to being educated by
people who are like okay great i'm not
taking your struggle away from you
however i want to point out a couple
things and then they just point out a
couple of facts that one is a great
example where okay you have a structure
and a system that is set up that
excludes people human beings just in
general white people too what straight
white guys as well it's exclusionary
because like a union is a good example
which is supposed to
be a form of solidarity for good reason
but at the same time when you have that
pool and there's only so much work then
it becomes exclusive to a certain point
and traditionally that exclusion has
kept out lots of different human beings
but most specifically women and other
marginalized people
so how do you break through those
structures and those systems it's going
to be messy and difficult and it's going
to take time and then the question
becomes well how much time motherfucker
because i've been waiting for a long
that's obviously what yeah a lot of
people say and rightfully so which is
how much time do you that's the james
baldwin quote like how much time you
fucking need like at a certain point
we're gonna come in and burn it down and
that's what we're seeing and i believe
that the culture
and the community again maybe
this is just maybe
too selfish but i think our shit is
better because of it
because we are whether we were forced
into it or not we are now in a position
where we we have to listen to other
points of view and then when you have
seven or eight different points of view
of really funny really talented people
together that's just automatically going
to make your ship better yeah so why not
why aren't you embracing that i don't
understand i think there's a fear of
like of like losing out like if i add
someone that's not like
the main quality if you say with comedy
like for me
like when i like for years and years
when i did stand up comedy i would only
until we got a female booker at zayn i
would only or clubs i would only get
booked on shows that were all women like
all women shows and i would only get to
open for women because there was no way
that a man
they're not gonna relate to you they're
not gonna find you funny so you would
only get that for so long i think people
are really scared to give well but then
you're being so in them but then whoever
was booking that not i mean lucy you're
the best but the person booking is going
well
you're actually in a weird way you're
being sexist and phobic but you're also
being sexist towards the men that are
coming to see the show because you think
all men are phobic all men don't think
that someone that you know so to me
there's a lot of
i'm just going to defend the white man
uh straight away thank
there's a lot of sexism and going like
oh guys won't find that funny no that's
you how you see guys like you're i know
plenty i mean all my girlfriends think
you're the funniest i mean you had the
same thing correct did you not get and
here comes your lady comic and everybody
goes to the bathroom and then because
it's like there's no way lady this next
comedian's beautiful what but then as
soon as as soon as we got the female
booker lucy it was just like night and
day it was like she's like no people can
like all kinds of things
but they're also never exposed to it
because you never book them so how are
they ever going to even know i'm really
appreciative for
for straight white men like you who have
these platforms because it makes all the
other ones go oh my god we can like so
many things yeah we can paint our nails
but we'll just call it war painting yeah
it's just i mean it's like okay it's
drywall that's true
but last thing like with the female
director's thing i get that because of
course i get this question all the time
which is like i'm are there no female
directors it's like okay so no one will
listen because i know actresses get to
drive this conversation the people that
aren't there when anyone's hired i i
you know i'm always like can we have
like a meeting with the line producers
those are people that actually hire
people and it's illegal to ask someone
their ethnicity it's illegal to ask
their age or their gender but they're
supposed to hire completely equally now
for this inclusion rider but they are
all white guys because that's how it
always has been and they just want to
call their guy they just want to call
their friend that delivers for them
every time and they how are they going
to find these people so i wanted to do
like a tinder for uh crew that was
because there's tons
of diverse crew in atlanta there's tons
on commercials they're just not you know
able to get in these unions and then
there's this thing where line producers
are all of a sudden supposed to know a
hundred asian grips like where where and
again i'm i'm i'm not asking for
sympathy because there's no
it's not i've made you sit here for
three hours you deserve something but
yeah if you didn't notice this this
podcast is like shares for a while it
just goes on and on and on
well i enjoyed it
and you know what howard does this he
always says last thing he knows there's
another one and that's not what i'm
doing last thing here's my thesis yeah
uh no but that that it is because of
california state labor law it is
really difficult
you can't say okay i would like to hire
a person of color for this particular
position because you can't ask somebody
say via like on a phone call certainly
anybody like you i want to hire very
specifically a gay a gay writer because
of i want that that point of view okay
right but uh how how can i ask someone
if they're gay no no you have to go are
you right well that's the thing i'm not
gay but are you so those provisions were
put into place to protect people
to be able to get right and what's
happening now is that you i had the
fucking weirdest conversation with
somebody recently where i said oh okay
i'm looking for a very specific voice
and i'm i'm looking for a
younger gay man uh someone who's grown
up in a generation where it's maybe a
little bit more acceptable than it was
and yeah yadda yadda so they sent me
these writers five writers and i was
like i can i read them and i said okay
these are all gay men and they said well
we
we can't say you said they look gay i'm
like well i said well are are they gay
and they're like we think so and we're
like well how do you think so they're
like they're actors you know they're
writers
literally you know
i'm like i do what do i know they're
like well we can guess i'm like
jesus fuck like we are now these are
professional adults who are saying well
we should just guess based on an
affectation based on a stereotype based
on whatever it is and we can't have an
open and honest conversation about it
motherfuckers we're not going to be able
to change anything if we can't talk
about it and then they're like dude they
said well their writing is in a lisa
frank notebook so we just assumed
um and then just with the um with and
this is something i think about caitlyn
uh when i when i want to talk about this
that's also the idea of people like well
there's only six percent uh female
directors that's that's the percentage
that say yes
i pass on everything because it's like i
don't first of all until there's child
care on sets women cannot say yes to
these directing jobs so a lot of times
offers are made to women to direct
movies that are kind of like they can't
say yes it doesn't count and they will
all the women passed yeah because they
have babe they have children they can't
go to new zealand for eight months you
know so there's this this thing where um
there's this there's only six percent
yeah because it's not hospitable same
thing with uh female gamers it's like
there's only this percent female gay or
uh women in stem or or whatever it's
like yeah because why would anyone want
to be here you know first it has to be
accommodating and then it will attract
them you know it's sort of it's that
kind of thing there's not enough female
writers yeah because most writers are my
i remember my first assistant i ever had
she was so brilliant and so funny i
hired her to be on the second season of
the nbc show
and then she got another job and she
went i actually don't want to be a
writer this is awful you know so it's
like we can't keep them either if it's
going to be like this you know so if
there's not child care if you still have
nine in and out trucks coming in every
you know uh episode but you're not
having you know someone and i even
offered the solution what if there's
some kind of director shadowing program
where you can a female can shadow a
director and then do child care starting
at three you know so the director's kids
can come and whatever so it's like it's
also not people love that statistic but
they don't want to look like look at
okay what if what if um 30 of all the
directors were female and they were
offered big movies this year but had to
pass like that's the statistic i'm way
more interested in well okay so this is
a you could do a whole podcast on this
because
the truth of the matter is like this is
part of the work and part of the issue
and part of the problem and
because you and i are on the other end
of things and we see that it and
everybody recognizes that it's a
systemic and structural problem right
and
so systems and structures can be torn
down and burned down great but something
needs to be built in instead to then
foster and facilitate a change and that
is hard yeah we love to burn it down
yeah that would never be a no without
effects you know that's my number one
rule that's yes and that is a really
difficult thing to do and so who's in
charge of that well i'm a boss and i'm
in charge of my television series and i
have to deliver a television series so
now i also want to be ethically and
socially responsible so i also have this
other thing i got to do great but then i
also have to help work with whitney and
other people to build now a whole new
structure a new system yeah and i think
a lot of us what you find is that we're
all game for it like everybody's into it
but then it's just it is truly a
shitload of work to deconstruct and then
reconstruct the system and so yes
again this is easy for me to say because
i i've had an easier road but it is
going to be hard and it's going to take
time and we're going to have to navigate
things and rebuild something and
surrender some opportunities sure sure
you know but but this is a system that
was set up over a century and a well
the entertainment industry right it was
a system that was set up by a very
specific group of people men uh a a long
time ago and then fostered for 150 years
130 years so so now great we're burning
it down what's the new system that we're
putting together and it's going to be a
it's going to be a very a very
intense and long collaboration
and then i think it's important that you
know and um i think i was talking about
this with donnell rawlings or something
not only give the person the opportunity
but when they get there don't walk on
eggshells around them or chat or treat
them differently so that they can't
underst like so they can be good at
their job and learn the job that's one
thing i see a lot of people hiring you
know african-american uh women and then
they're just like is that okay is that
okay is that good like what no she has
to be the homeowner she's the arbiter
now she's the hr department yes and also
don't treat them like your trophy where
you're like look what i did oh my gosh
well look at my trans writer there is a
well look what i look at my gay
character like then it's like okay
there was a one show runner who posted a
photo of uh like like a writer's room
and there's a native american writer and
when they went to go post the show was
like no you come next to i'm not going
to say the names you come next to me and
she was like it was very clear like she
just wanted to pose next to me in the
photo and she never like takes any my
jokes or hasn't given me a script to
write yet yeah it was just like that
idea let's take a picture together so
it's like the performative activism
stuff i heard you talk about this on
something i'm so
relieved that we're so aligned on this
because there's no one i can talk to
about this which is the kind of thing of
like you know posting on social media
you're the one benefiting from that when
you benefit about it
to retweet someone else who needs the
followers who doesn't know what they're
talking about just like give an
opportunity to someone else like give
your platform to someone else for the
day or whatever like because a lot of
the self-serving
justice warriors shit it's only but
you're just getting more likes and your
metrics are getting up and people think
you're a good person and so you just
used them again you just exploited the
very time
on that that's why like you ever noticed
like
the moment that like
a male actor
mentions that he supports his gay fans
they're like on the cover of every gay
magazine they win awards they're like
you're like what you know by the way you
don't get points for that so that's the
other thing with you i noticed every one
of your interviews uh at the end of the
beginning this guy is such a nice he's
the nicest guy this guy he is such i'm
like yes of course but we shouldn't be
giving out points for that i'm saying
how weird is it that we're in a field
where we give points for something that
should just be expected but i will say
that i noticed that that
have you noticed this like oh you met oh
i met um
oh you know who i met uh um forest
whitaker yeah i'm at forest whitaker oh
is he a nice guy that's always the first
thing that i hear people say like oh um
you know i met michael jordan nice guy
such a nice guy because i think people
are surprised
when they hear about it yes i think you
want to
you want people to be kind and you want
to know that like the people you look up
to
right and you're like oh was he or she
was she cool but it's definitely more
dudes than anything because there's been
so much duplicity and this guy was my
hero and then i found out that he was
like watching this you know it's like i
think people have been duped so much uh
recently that i i see that but there
used to be a time where everyone just
assumed all actors were assholes like
and assumed all producers were assholes
like it was it was that's how it was you
know and it's it's really fascinating to
me that um you know it'll be interesting
to see how
people in this business which is the
stock market i mean it's like a business
like any other one it's a corporate run
business will change when people are
sort of trying to do the right thing
it'll be interesting to see now because
it's you know evolution wise it used to
be sort of survival of the strongest you
know um doggy dog who could eat the most
dogs now it's going to be survival of
the nicest yeah in a way well meg and i
are always talking about this which is
like you know if if the system was set
up paternalistically which it obviously
was okay great so now
so now let's just say theoretically the
system could be set up maternalistic or
just from a different from a different
point of view how much does it deviate
from the system that we currently live
in i'm sure in some ways dramatically in
other ways not as much and so what's
great about being alive right now is
that we're sort of like at the forefront
of that and it's going to be determined
by us and then i mean by i don't mean by
me i mean by us as a generation and then
most importantly than that yeah and i'm
going to play around actually yes
sexually abusive behavior in a workplace
or any any environment is no longer
tolerated and therefore scorched earth
great okay very clear well i've been on
a couple sets recently but you know what
else
i was on some really um like open s like
a closed nudity set was open and people
are taking pictures inviting friends and
that kind of thing i've been in that
situation recently yeah but there's also
i'll tell you the story but also when i
come onto your set and have a nude scene
or agree to play a character that's sexy
or something
please don't treat me like i'm about to
sue you at any moment and like i just
show up to sets to get like when they're
like is that okay yeah i said yes to the
job the joke was in the script like i
would love to do this like okay but if
you want to change it like i don't and
then like you know the sound guy going
in i'm like no dude you got to do your
job i'm not suing you like just this
thing of you know when you're in your
nude scenes or whatever i was like are
you okay is everything fine i'm like
okay i just
i know you guys are trying to like
protect women because you respect women
but can you give me the benefit of the
doubt that if i need something i'll let
you know yeah and then please listen to
me moving forward you don't have to
check on me every five seconds like like
i got this you know well we so we
started using an intimacy coordinator on
on mythicquest and it's like
why they weren't doing this from the
beginning
there's a lot of jokes about them and
shit like i've heard but it's truly the
greatest it's the it's the greatest
because you have a third party whose job
it is there to make everybody feel
comfortable and it's somebody that you
can pull aside who actively is there i
like pasties i just need a new pair of
like yes you know and so that it doesn't
put you now you're a very assertive
person you're a boss right so you walk
into a set and you feel very comfortable
saying to everybody fuck off i'm doing
this i'm doing that guest star that
comes in i know a lot of actors who
don't feel as comfortable and then they
don't they want to go along for the ride
and they're like oh things are moving
fast and the director asked me to do
this and director's not a bad person but
he or she's just trying to make their
day and all of a sudden i don't feel
comfortable doing this and then they
feel exploited and rightfully so and so
now you have a third party who's in
there that's like it's my fault i'm the
only one that's taking on the
responsibility i'm going to you're not
crazy you're not overreacting i'm just
doing my job i'm also for the for the
for the um for the sound guy and the
producers i'm also
going to mitigate against any litigation
i'm the bad guy i'm the bad guy and if
there's a problem it's it's my fault
and and if i see there's another human
being on here who's the problem i'm
going to make it their fault because
it's their fault and i'm going to take
this to hr and what's great is that it
allows for what i found is that allows
for the sep to become that much more
confident i get obsessed though with new
jobs that never existed five years ago
what's that person's background resume
that how did it's a new job you didn't
go to school for it it's just what is
that is it advertising is it is it legal
i asked the girl that was with me on a
shoot i did recently and i think she was
in
just she was just in production she was
like a pa for a real long time so she
just kind of knew all the crazy shit
that goes down yeah you know she was
like if people are gonna sleep in the
same bed you put
one under the
both covers and then one under between
the sheet and the covers like she just
had to do it a lot as a piano what i
found crazy is how often i would talk to
specifically actresses but also actors
where you know where
i would say this is even before we did
the intimacy stuff i had the institute
coordinator i would say hey um like
let's have a conversation about this
like weeks before so we can talk about
this might be awkward i just want to
like be open to where you are and
then they'd be like oh god thank god i i
the last job we just showed up
and everybody was so nervous even the
director was like oh i don't know what
to it's all awkward and no one's a
professional all of a sudden everybody's
really like they they turned 12 years
old again when there's a sex scene what
the fuck is it
yes why isn't somebody stepping up and
saying like this is a professional set
and we're we're all professionals like
let's talk about this in advance let's
prep this the way we would prep a stuff
we're all too scared to talk about it
it's that it's that like deep religious
sort of um programming of like we're
talking about a stunt yeah we're talking
about how we're gonna how we're gonna
blow the car up are we in a simulation
i i'm not smart enough to answer
i just feel like you have had to talk
about that on in your writer's room we
have discussed it yeah
unfortunately it's a bunch of actors and
and comedy writers so i haven't gotten
to the bottom of it yeah but i think
that's kind of i think it's amazing to
me because we're all like arena
simulation it's like when you're a
writer you get to make a simulation yeah
which is kind of cool yeah the idea that
someone's writing our lines it's like
okay no i would like to have credit for
that thing i just said not the video
game guy i'm i'm open to the weird and
and and
wondrously strange
uh experience of being alive i have no
fucking idea what that means or where it
comes from but i'm just trying to i'm
just trying to be
as open as i can navigate it can i just
say like you know this is you're such a
good writer because of this too the most
emotionally um examined people the
people that look at themselves that are
self-aware that want to um heal old
invisible wounds and stuff also happen
to be the best writers i believe like
when i'm watching what you did with um
uh hornsby and the
projecting his mother onto every i mean
that clearly there was a very deep
understanding of psychology and you work
very hard at that and i think that
that's what makes great comedians also
but i think when people are like i just
i don't know what to do i don't know how
to be a writer like start learning that
stuff because you're writing characters
and human beings and you need to be able
to empathize with them and then defend
them when they do something indefensible
and understand why they're doing what
they're doing have you seen any of the
second season of methods i've seen a lot
of it well yeah the um
i have but uh i miss i had to skip
through two there's two i haven't seen
okay so just watch the standalone we
deal with a lot we do with this very
thing quite a bit fascinating trying to
empathize not to excuse behavior but to
empathize with the characters you
wouldn't normally empathize with to at
least get a gain a better understanding
of why people are the way they are
because there's also anytime someone
comes with anger i'm like you're sad
you're sad and this is your your rage is
your hell you're self-soothing like i
i'm at such a hardcore you know it
drives you nuts what are you doing yeah
i know i'm just saying it drives you
nuts when you come in or like we talk
about some of that person i don't like
it well because my therapist trained me
i have this i love you tattoo right here
in white which is um
uh
i was talking about someone that had
been really shitty to me on a job and i
was like and then they said this and
then they said this and then they
wouldn't let me do this and they
wouldn't let me do another take and it
was so clear that they were trying to
not let me whatever and um she goes wow
sounds like they're in a lot of pain
and i was like it like blew my whole
world open and now i just see when
people lose their temper as like a like
a 12 year old that just like is scared
yeah and it changes your life oh yeah
it's just hard to have empathy when
you're out of ten and so if you're like
and we're all out of ten when we feel
like we're being attacked
it's just
it's only in retrospect where you can
look back and be like oh right
we're going to stop talking
thank you
you're going to find are you going to
cut you're not going to make it this
long in the actual show are you oh we
never do look at me talking okay all of
my lines and replace them with um
i re i re-record everything later and i
put jokes in vicky
small wonderful
small wonder i do have a video of me
crying with my face not moving at all
and i was like because i just want to
see if i could do it remember you know
when i lie down and cry because if you
have a lot of makeup on and you need to
cry you have to lie down so that it
doesn't fuck everything up one but one
of the greatest now i'm still talking
but uh one of the greatest um rumors of
all time with regards to television and
pop culture is
that um that jamie the actor that played
uh jamie was actually the lead singer of
smashing pumpkins
because he looks exactly exactly like
him
you never heard that
i did recently hear that may west uh
might have been black or a man or heard
that part
really mm-hmm you never heard that i've
heard the man thing yeah yeah
last night in the ancestry test episode
i had when david sinclair was on he's
australian and apparently australian
ancestry poppy because of the fact that
it was like criminals mostly that
inhabited it they have this like really
violent like shame about their violent
past there's something really
interesting about that to me
okay we'll eat into it
put it on the
board because that's all
when i was watching that show i was like
i'm so clear on the psychiat the
psychology of the characters like i
gotta know their ancestry will you come
in and help break it with us yes okay
yes i will
yes i love you don't write elephants i
am these like incredibly weird
would you like to promote
yeah i was like did you have the last
word
that's such a great way to end it
but people are gonna be like where can
we watch the show where can we follow oh
i don't care about that you don't know
how to watch this i'll be standing in
philadelphia or mythicquest at this
point there's nothing i can do to help
you there's just nothing we could pay
their cable bill i don't know what to
tell you guys you figure out a way to
watch big bang theory on a plane
[Music]
you